oh my god look what's happening ladies
and gentlemen
welcome to fat man beyond i'm kevin
smith i'm mark bernard
hey oh my god look what's happening
ladies and gentlemen
welcome to facts what's with the what
he's wearing that old outfit and [ __ ]
like that that's right
i went back to classic duds for this
episode got dressed
because we got special guests we're
gonna bring on later on ladies and
gentlemen
so i put on my sunday best today oh
so nice uh how you been doing mr mark
i'm gonna put on a funny hat while you
talk
fair enough uh i'm doing pretty good man
i'm doing pretty good it's been
it's been a week uh every week feels
like it's a week
today i've been uh i've been tickled to
see that somebody's trying to
to brute force back their way into my
twitter account
um yeah like because i have the
two-factor authorization on there which
means that
if you want to reset my password it
needs to send me a code
and i've gotten like 50 texts from
twitter
saying the new code for your account is
blah blah blah
somebody's trying to to work their way
into my into my password so
it's not working but i'm sorry i just
wanted to post a few dick pics i didn't
think you'd take it so personally
i mean i have no problem with with mr
grayson
appearing all over my twitter account
that's fine by me
um but yeah weird when when you
you know like in the world of credit
sometimes your credit card company is
like hey somebody tried to use your card
and you're like what that's so [ __ ]
weird
in twitter you almost find out real time
that somebody is trying to defraud you
you know with that notice where it's
like i didn't [ __ ] do that oh my god
it's happening as we speak
and somewhere out in the world somebody
who's listened to a lot of fat man
beyond
is trying to figure out your past
they're going like jeff's
kiss try to hack the [ __ ] try to
get inside your mind man how strong
is your password it's so strong i don't
remember it
good one right there that's perfect i
can't get into it
um it's fairly robust i mean i i also
don't i'm not the guy who's like
google have at it like just put 15
random characters together and then i'm
going to trust
you to know how to get into my [ __ ] like
i still kind of need to know what it is
but there's like letters that should be
numbers and random [ __ ]
symbols in there i think i'm okay but
it's uh it is always endearing to see
somebody trying so hard
what's the worst thing they could post
from your account from your perspective
like love for some shittily written
thing that you'd be like oh
oh take thy peep from out my heart how
dare you
that's how dare you betray my artistic
critical integrity you finish dying
yeah i i don't i don't know i don't know
it's just like
boy i love white people
pretty sure i've seen that tweet on your
account from time to time i know
because it's true however um yeah i i
remember somebody hacked my account one
day
and you go check this this happened at
one point um
and like said i just want to come out to
the world and announce that i'm
gay or something like that and so you
know when i got my account back
i was just like look you all know that
wasn't me
because i told you years ago that you
know i [ __ ] lean
in yawn direction so clearly it i was
hacked
it is a bizarre feeling when somebody
kind of comes in and shits i would
imagine it's kind of like the feeling of
somebody breaking into your house where
you're just like well that was
unsettling
right like there's some stuff gone
actually just
moved around like nobody took anything
they just moved some [ __ ]
like so now did you invade my space but
you didn't even do what i thought you'd
do
so that's just been today whoever's
doing this
leave leave him alone leave mark alone
for heaven's sake come on
jesus promise i like the snyder cut you
don't have to do this
i appreciate your restraint sir yes
thank you i'm trying to
i know some things kids i've
i didn't mean to underhand softball you
that that easily
i can't yeah i know i'm it's i'm if you
could see me having a struggle to keep
my mouth shut
yeah which is adorable
i'm not i'm kids i'm not a visionary
but i have seen some things we'll talk
about that
in a couple of weeks on the road ladies
and gentlemen
but i know i'm not allowed to just
this is that's all i'm allowed to do all
right on that one thing i will ask
you if you did see which i know you can
talk about is coming
to america loved it absolutely loved it
it's been a fantastic weekend of
watching [ __ ] starting on thursday night
with wanda vision but coming to america
was my friday night
uh with my wife and uh my god
i had such a blast um i i don't know
what anyone else was looking for in the
movie
but i was wholly satisfied
um a real love fest i mean like look is
the guy who made jane salam bob reboot
which i'm not saying is
like this movie at all but very you know
hey let's go back in time and [ __ ]
have a good time and hope people
enjoy it as well and by the way we'll
bring back as many familiar faces as
possible
um you know i i've recognized
the kindred spirit in coming to america
uh that all being said
it satisfied me on every [ __ ] level
um uh
you know spoilers there's even a duke
and duke cameo for heaven
you know and that's what i was there for
i was there to see the same movie and i
got the same movie essentially
a kind of modern update i was there to
watch characters i've [ __ ] loved for
three decades
uh come together i couldn't believe the
amount of fan service they provided
uh in terms of bringing anybody
who's still around and or some
incarnation
you know bringing them put him on screen
during the movie even people who are in
the original who did not return
still kind of got to return in flashback
moments
um i don't want to spoil anything but
you know one of the actors i'm talking
about
very famous cameo for the first one that
you know
shows up again they replay the cameo but
he didn't return in a role
very one of the few that didn't return i
mean from america
um delightful [ __ ] romp
one of my favorite moments hands down
was uh i i guess we i don't want to
spoil it but
there is a [ __ ] use of a prince song
not an obscure prince song but a
fantastic prince song
that as they started the performance i
was like are you serious
not only did they do like the you know
because it's a
it's a handoff song where sometimes a
woman sings sometimes
it's get off they did [ __ ] get off
and they did the rap part as well
which i was like it was stunning so the
whole [ __ ] thing was absolute joy and
fun
i don't know what the internet's saying
about it because personally i'm too old
to give a [ __ ] if people are unhappy and
[ __ ]
i was incredibly happy it just filled me
with joy
watching the [ __ ] thing man uh and uh
it didn't occur to me
that coming to america wasn't rated
pg-13
until afterwards like you know it was
like a horror movie
it's that's what i'm saying like is the
only things i remember about it being
our like the royal penis is clean sir
and she was topless and eddie murphy
being like yes
[ __ ] you too but generally speaking that
never occurs to me like as a
hard r rated rated r movie so the pg-13
that we saw
for coming to america i didn't bump into
it all i think craig brewer
did a fantastic job i mean you know he
was not the guy who made the original he
was a [ __ ]
infant when that was going on or like in
single digits maybe
maybe maybe 10 or whatever [ __ ] that
was like 30 years ago
you know the original was john landis
but i thought this was
stood shoulder to shoulder with it now
for anybody that's like
[ __ ] you blah blah i can't be as good as
coming to america
give it 30 [ __ ] years like we all
loved coming to america when it came out
but it wasn't like an instant classic
it's earned that [ __ ] over multiple
viewings multiple years and stuff
um will this have the exact same legacy
i probably not the world doesn't work
the way that it used to
that being said it's a welcome addition
to you know what what is now the the
eddie murphy universe
uh as they're trying to pull in i read
an article where they were talking about
um doing a do uh what was it
it was a more it was an oh the clumps he
talked about
at one scene he was gonna have the
clumps do a cameo
and then he was like it was just way too
expensive but like
you know eddie eddie's trying to eddie
murphy versus it man which i think is
kind of
fun what were your what were your
thoughts do you watch uh i did watch i
did watch
um i i didn't love it as much as you did
um but i also what a shock mark what a
surprise
um but i think that it it functions and
it delivers
on the nostalgia you have for the first
movie quite a bit
um but it you know there's
the the thing that i love about the
first movie hey it's incredibly sweet
you know and
and eddie murphy is is playing a
character who
is willing to learn and like
aggressively kind of push
the boundaries of what's expected of him
um
and i feel like like a keem in this
movie has kind of gone the other way
whereas akeem has gotten very sedentary
in his opinions and his beliefs
and needs to be shocked into something
resembling progression right where it's
you know part of this whole story is
he's only had daughters
and he's got three daughters but he
needs a son to take over
as as the king of zemunda um which is
very based in sort of a patriarchal
traditional society whereas in the first
movie he's all about bucking
this the the tradition and the rituals
and so forth and so on
but the thing that that i guess bothered
me a little bit about
the second one the first movie is very
much poking fun at what it means to be
black american what it means to be
african-american you know the zamundans
have it all figured out and then he gets
to the states and then
the jokes are look at look at eric
lasalle's hair and the soul glow on the
couch and look at the weird caricatures
in this church
and look at the kind of shallowness of
some of these people except for lisa who
seems to be
you know has their head screwed on right
like the the bougie new money
of the of the mcdowell's versus the old
money and some
sort of wisdom of of the uh the jeffers
whereas this movie sort of pokes fun at
the africans
you know and like you who are the ones
who don't quite understand how the world
should work
luckily we have this family from queens
who can come in and offer some
insight to it and just that that sort of
evolution
felt a little backwards to me um and
that's
purely just me as as a viewer as always
your mileage may vary
um but i think that that there's
there's much to like in it i think eddie
there's moments in this movie where
eddie just leans into being regal
and delivers a sort of eddie murphy that
i haven't seen before and it's actually
kind of welcome it's like dude
you're actually a really good dramatic
actor and like you could do this if you
wanted to do this
um and then there were moments i mean
wesley snipes was having
the most fun of anybody i've ever seen
ever it's so much fun to watch them do i
read an interview with them where they
were like um
you know uh like how did you do it so
funny or whatever it's like i was
playing dramatic
that's all i do um but yeah like i i
liked it quite a bit
but i do think that there was some some
level of sort of
heart that was missing and a little bit
of of
awareness that that was missing but that
is just for me i had a lovely time
watching on a saturday night with the
family
because it goes down way easy it really
does and like
i'm so glad that amazon you know this
was a paramount
picture that they were going to release
in theaters and stuff and then amazon
came along and
snapped it up um good for them
because it's a great acquisition who the
[ __ ] isn't going to watch it
and yeah and probably benefits as well
from you know home viewing as opposed to
like i [ __ ] got dressed up and had to
go to a movie theater and [ __ ]
it wasn't the experience i had 30 years
ago you know what i'm saying like it
it softens the curve a bit as well but
oh my god i had such a good time
watching it
for sure um all right we got a show for
you tonight kids we got some wand
division of course to get into the
the seas series finale sadly
although maybe our guests can can shed a
little light on whether that's true
might be able to do that we'll hold on
to our guests for a second until we uh
talk about or tonight we got a sponsor
uh folks uh two sponsors the first of
which
are good friends at native nativedeo.com
ladies and gentlemen you've heard us
talk about native before you know why
because we don't like to stank
right before i did this show i went and
took a shower
put native all over my body work my
bosoms and stuff like that
native everywhere i smell like native
right now you smell that lavender of
course you
that is [ __ ] there man native uh
lives in my shower ladies and gentlemen
and not just because
they do ads on the show and whatnot my
wife
buys native behind my back not even
knowing that we do ads i was watching a
youtube video in the room before
and she was and somebody the guy was
doing a spot he mentioned
[ __ ] native and stuff and my wife
goes oh we have native
i said native pays for this house
without that native money you'd be out
on the streets i says without them
sponsoring fat man beyond i said you
drop down your needs you give thanks to
natives she says i do
with or without the money because it's a
fine product she just loves it
and so since she buys it puts it in the
shower that's what i [ __ ] use man i
used to be a bar
soap guy kids you know if i can lather
it up with a goddamn bar soap
now i get my soap it's called the body
wash
that's what it's called now mark soap is
now body wash
and native makes three different body
washes that are in my shower
that i alternate throughout the days man
i'm just saying i actually use this
product i can vouch for it what about
you
i am surprised that there was never a
prince album called body wash
because that sounds like just the right
kind of clean dirty
why was that guy such a slacker who
accomplished nothing
he could have had a album called body
wash he could have
but listen native deo it's uh it's
awesome you're smelling like lavender
today they got 10 different scents
including classics and rotating
seasonals including like coconut and
vanilla most popular
kev's favorite lavender and rose
cucumber and mint citrus and herbal musk
i want to smell herbal musky you know
and hey if you're more into your own
natural scent
they have an unscented option that will
still keep you from stinking
that's the important part of this
equation kids take away all the
fanciness
nobody wants to stink nobody wants to
offend we all want to be able to stand
amongst our peers and whatnot and not
have them be like
you smell like [ __ ] native they they're
the ones who didn't make sure that'll
never happen to you man
nativedeo.com is the address you go to
isn't there some sort of promotional
code
there is indeed nativedeo.com fat man
or use the promo code fat man at
checkout get 20 off
your first order don't drink it
don't pour it in your eyes pour it on
your head and your body
wash it up man you will smell amazing we
love native we thank native
for being sponsors of the proud sponsors
of fat man beyond
uh native deo.com slash
modcast ladies and gentlemen go to this
podcast what was it fat man
fat man the hat's too tight
it really is i forgot where i was i went
back in time for that one
he did slash fat man or use a promo code
fat man at checkout for 20
off your first order nativedeo.com stop
stanking
um all right shall we dive in
uh right before uh thursday night of
course and [ __ ] 1201 i was refreshing
over and over and over on disney plus um
because the last few weeks man if you
hit it at midnight
there's been a not a cue but like a slow
like it broke the internet i yeah i
guess so everyone's been hitting it once
it was a little frustrating um but bam
once it began
uh i dove in and i watched that episode
three times before i went to bed that
night
bald each uh time harder and harder
each time i watch it i watched it just
before after i took my shower i was
laying on the bed drying it so i'm gonna
rewatch it before we talk about it
tonight
and probably one of the most moving
[ __ ] things i've ever seen in my life
spoilers kids we're gonna spoil the [ __ ]
out of wanda vision particularly the
series finale one of the most moving
things i've ever watched in my life in
any
entertainment whatsoever movie tv show
comic book any media even a song
is watching [ __ ] vision and wanda say
goodbye when he
sees that [ __ ] wall coming and he
knows the end is near
and he's just like you know we have said
before goodbye before so it stands to
reason
and she's like we'll say hello again
i'll live my entire life i'll never
write something as [ __ ] beautiful as
that
so incredibly [ __ ] profoundly
beautiful
um as we learned at the end of all this
of course you know going into it we
suspect
this is a series about [ __ ] grief and
it absolutely was it was about grief it
was about
closure and we got a lot of that for
that final episode man
uh not only did we get to see a marvel
witch battle in the sky
which was stellar not only did did we
get to see vision
battle the white vision straight out you
know imagery straight out the comics
um we got to see a battle that didn't
end with
just people beating the [ __ ] out of each
other we got to see a battle of the
minds it wasn't even a battle
it was a philosophical discussion that
was like a star trek fight
like at one point all of a sudden they
just started they stopped talk is
fighting
and they started having a conversation
and the conversation was about as
gripping
as any fight you they could have
presented i don't care how well they
could have presented it
the hearing who knew that the series
finale of wanda
vision would be predicated on the ship
of theseus like
what what a delight as it happened you
know this entire series has been a
delight and
it gave you some things you were hoping
it was and then gave you a bunch of
things you didn't know were coming
uh some folks on the internet uh you
know of course ran
rampant with theories and then felt
disappointed i guess to some degree when
their theories didn't come true i
operate in a completely different way
you know i eat what's given to me and
what was given to me was one of the most
sumptuous [ __ ] banquets
i've ever enjoyed in my life like
aside from just the personal
satisfaction of of how enjoyable wanda
vision was for me
somebody who grew up with these
characters somebody who literally
collected and had
mail away sent to him his subscription
to vision in this and the scarlet witch
series
from marvel years ago i would get in a
plain brown [ __ ] rapper
so naturally i got some pornography like
just like playboy mark
naturally i had some skin in the game
i've loved these movies since they've
been doing them and stuff and then when
i
got the hint from the trailers what it
was i was like this is gonna be my jam
so i was pre-programmed to like this a
little bit
all they had to do was not drop the ball
not only did not not only do they
execute properly they [ __ ] elevated
made something
singular for the ages and stuff but
again
i've said it before i'll say it again
this
show ultimately is about how important
it is to find someone to watch tv with
in this world and i watch this whole
[ __ ] thing with the person that i
watch
tv with somebody who doesn't normally go
for this sort of thing
isn't a marvel zombie like myself you
know does
can't quote this [ __ ] chapter and verse
so i suspected this would work on me
the fact that my wife was bawling it
by the season finale by the series
finale and whatnot
uh by the the cheering out loud as if we
were in a [ __ ] movie theater as if
cat you know once wanda revealed moves
over their camera moves and reveals
the runes written behind wanda on the
walls of the hex
you know my wife's over there going
clapping like just like i would and [ __ ]
in a movie theater and
to to elicit that kind of response
from what i would consider to be a
non-consumer
look we got no other term for that but
jeff's kiss ladies and gentlemen
absolutely jeff's kiss uh your thoughts
sir
um i mean i i you know i have been
critical of this show and and i and i
feel like it would be disingenuous to
say that i hadn't been
um but i think a thing that i learned
especially watching
lost um is that there there are any
number of
questions that show can ask um and it is
not
to a certain degree responsible for
answering all of them beyond the
emotional truth
at its core you know and i think that at
the end of this series like yeah there
were there were things that that
people in the audience myself included
you know were sort of chasing
like rabbit holes we all kind of ran
down but by the end of it
you know that that idea of
dealing with grief in a very real way
and learning that the only way out is
through
and that for one they needed to be the
the
the resolution of this show needed to be
emotional and i needed to be those two
people
and it needed to be a goodbye and what
it was the context for that to buy
what's the the portrayal of that
farewell and what does it mean
to her to have to finally let the guard
down
and understand what she's feeling and
process it and deal with it move past it
and so to get that final sequence
between the two of them to get the
putting your kids to bed one last time
to get the which i
i very much dug the turning off the
light you know which is sort of a
classic cities the cheers like we're
turning off the light in the bar
you know one last time but then vision
is unwilling to turn that light off
because he wants one last look
you know like i think all of those
things land with so much heart
and so much empathy that you know at the
end of the day
we watch television because the
characters are the ones leading us
through it
and it's not about the the easter eggs
that you hoped you would get or the
story revelations you hoped you would
get
it's about these characters and their
mission and their journey
and how they resolve it at the end and
this ending felt
right to me you know it felt rewarding
to me and it felt like the ending
it felt like the landing you wanted to
have you know it's a little bit bumpy
at times because emotions are bumpy you
know and it's a little bit
um fraught because emotional journeys
are always a bit fraught
but i think there's a grace with which
it ended that
that made for me the the ride worthwhile
i'll tell you what right now shya tony
stark himself
wanda maximoff may be the best developed
character
in the marvel cinematic universe now
granted they've had like a lot more time
to tell her story
but just as compelling if not
more compelling than tony stark a story
at this point and when you look at the
movie and that has everything all hats
off to wanavision because
i watched that youtube video with like
all wanda's clips
and it's it ain't like two hours it's
[ __ ] like 25
35 minutes or something like that so
throughout the movies just enough
details
sketchy details about this character and
then they took this entire wonderful
series to like
shade her in to add dimension add color
and the story's not done
they just kind of reintroduced us
wanda maximov as the scarlet witch i
thought it was so cute that in the
series at one point hayward's asking
about like you know doesn't she have a
[ __ ] funny name or she don't have a
funny name
just so that everyone knew like nobody
calls her the
scarlet witch just one more time before
we head into this nobody calls it a
scarlet witch so that by the time you
get to
you know the second to last episode and
[ __ ] agatha is just like
that makes you the scarlet witch
suddenly everybody's like oh [ __ ]
that means something more than it would
have normally [ __ ] meant
this series gave us katherine hahn an
incredible addition to the marvel
cinematic universe uh almost like a lady
loki at this point man you hope that she
they keep bringing her back
and based on her last interaction with
wanda it seems like she can go back to
her you know she knows exactly where she
is so she could come back
playing and then have magic
conversations with her
um boy they leaned into magic in a big
bad way man i mean they've done it
before with doctor strange and stuff but
like
watching a witch fight in the skies
you know and i thought the in terms of
the look of it
like you know we were essentially in the
third act of an action movie with this
final episode
and we've seen third acts of marvel
movies before and they're very [ __ ]
big and there's lots of things going on
at once different story lines to tie up
i thought for you know something that
was sold as a series this was about as
cinematic as it [ __ ] gets
felt like a movie felt like i could have
been watching that on the big screen not
at home on
well my equally big screen or or you
know watching on a laptop
i have a big screen home no bra i don't
mean to brag but it felt
cinematic i guess for lack of a better
description
um i saw you know i put up a tweet where
i was
crying and [ __ ] like that and i kind of
quasi-quoted the show where i said
um you know we'll we'll we'll meet again
goodbye i want a vision we'll meet again
or whatever the [ __ ]
um then of course i put that up on
instagram and twitter uh some
many [ __ ] attacked me attacked me for
you know being all emotional and [ __ ]
like that
my point to them was i wasn't even
smoking weed all last week because i had
the periodontal surgery
so i watched that show clean bro
there wasn't a there wasn't a thc
molecule bouncing around my [ __ ] body
anymore
i watched that [ __ ] just as crisp as you
or jc [ __ ] squares all
normy not [ __ ] with the you know the
[ __ ] devil's cabbage and [ __ ] like
so i watched it completely straight up
so much so you could never be like he
smokes too much weed and cries
everything
so i was a hate tank without my weed
like you know not
i was in the opposite position i should
have been like [ __ ] this and [ __ ] her
and [ __ ] all this
instead it absolutely captured my
imagination
melted my heart and so i was crying i
put up a picture and i was quick to
point out
hey man like that's not even high kevin
smith crying that's just how [ __ ]
beautiful
this show is it was everything i wanted
to be and then some
[ __ ] like you know wrote
dissertations about like
you suck and i'm like well i know people
have been telling me that for 27 years
but why do you think so today
and their point mark was that i don't
have enough critical thinking
to properly enjoy a thing because only
with critical thinking
would i see the flaws and hence not
enjoy it as much
this logic makes no sense to me
whatsoever they're like
your problem is you like it too much you
need to
not like it as much as you like and
their point was like with all the marvel
things i like
like i'm just not discerning or whatever
the [ __ ] and now just because i love a
thing don't mean that i can't
you know [ __ ] pick on and be like hey
this could or they could or blah blah
blah
but that's not enough for me to change
an opinion of a thing like i found this
incredibly sweeping i you know i'm not
just a guy who like loves superhero [ __ ]
i [ __ ] tell stories for a living now
i know how the sausage is made and [ __ ]
so when when you see me caught up in it
like
one of two things you know either i'm an
idiot which i probably am
or two even the magician
gets [ __ ] moved even the magician
buys into that [ __ ] act
and is like holy [ __ ] how'd that where'd
the rabbit come from
that's how good they are at their jobs
over there at marvel and
one division no exception like i wish
now
almost this was the model going forward
[ __ ] two hour movies
you give me eight nine hours of a
character that i could really dive into
and [ __ ] get to know
deeper and love and [ __ ] the stakes oh
my
god [ __ ] everything about it was just
so
perfectly attuned to me almost like it
was made
for me and stuff and then what i found
out as we watched it and you watched the
world fall in love with it as well
it wasn't made for me it was made for
everybody everybody could groove on this
[ __ ] now
i just don't understand why somebody
would be like no no no you got to
rethink this that you don't like it as
much
why the [ __ ] would i ever do something
like that that's like
madness to me so you know for anybody
that's like where's the critical thought
about it i don't i don't have any it's
that simple like
i i love a thing i love a [ __ ] thing
and this thing i love and
all of these marvel things i love and
maybe there'll be one day
where i hit one of them where i'm like i
don't give so much a [ __ ] about this
it could be the eternals it was never
going to be one division i'll tell you
that much right now
the moment they announced that [ __ ] i
was like oh my god i'm half in the bag
for this
all they have to do is not drop the ball
and not only do they execute they
[ __ ] elevate it
but like you know the eternals i'm not
like [ __ ] like oh i grew up with it
so that'll be up to them to charm me
over but they've done it before
with guardians of the galaxy twice you
know i went into that
marvel movie not giving a [ __ ] and i
walked out going
jesus even this so like i
i i'm telling you man if you're looking
for somebody
to like pull the strings and [ __ ] be
you know like
remotely you know [ __ ] well i don't
like it because x y and z i'm sorry kids
i'm not the guy i'm [ __ ] 50 years old
the only things i'll talk about are the
things that i
deeply [ __ ] love the things that move
me the things that i think are [ __ ]
powerful
now does that mean i love everything
[ __ ] no but you will never hear me talk
about the [ __ ]
that i don't like why bother there's no
time it was like
[ __ ] reading that person's reaction
like he needs to be more critical i'm
like
why so that i can be as [ __ ] bitter
and obtuse and not like something like
you let me like a thing i like it
because i like it like [ __ ] it
especially
something well made and i don't think i
got to convince anybody that like
give wanda vision the benefit of the
doubt it's [ __ ] epic storytelling
great [ __ ]
tv in the in the making we got to watch
it [ __ ] happen live
with characters and ip that we've fallen
in love with
over the course of 10 years in [ __ ]
movies so
i'm sorry kids if you want somebody to
like you know pick it [ __ ]
talk to that guy over there he's happy
you heard what he said about coming to
america oh my god
that's the dynamic of this partnership
you guys yes
you want the truth he can handle the
truth
my truth is this i'm back
yes he's the bad cop on the good cop
according to the internet mark i'm the
tasteless cop the cop who just
likes it all and [ __ ] like that no
filter whatsoever but
let me tell you man i almost died a few
years ago so i know one day i am going
to die
and when i leave this world you know
what's not going to make me feel good
going like
i'm sure glad i [ __ ] told them what i
thought of that [ __ ]
what's gonna make me feel good i'm
telling you if somebody told me you're
gonna [ __ ] die in 24 hours
i would do a lot of things try to pack a
lot of living one of the only things
that would make sure i do before i left
this world
is watch that ending scene for [ __ ]
monovision not the ending scene but like
the moment where
he's like [ __ ] so you can sell he's
scared because [ __ ] death is coming
it was it was like
crazy emotional when he was just like
we've said before we've said goodbye
before so it stands to reason and she's
like we'll say
hello again and she's all teary and [ __ ]
like that i
profoundly [ __ ] beautiful profoundly
beautiful and
you don't get moments like that without
a steady
studied [ __ ] hand behind it so
tonight ladies and gentlemen we got a
guest
someone who's not only knows a little
bit about wanda vision but ain't without
him there is no [ __ ] wine division
a name that we hated the entire series
of wanda vision because every time that
name came up we were like [ __ ]
because it meant the episode was over uh
now
we bring that name up and praise that
name because
he took us on such an amazing journey
and gave us something
i'll never forget i'll be watching this
[ __ ] you know till the end of time i'll
still you know i got disney plus now
forever
i'll still be popping by to watch like
that [ __ ] last scene
or to watch you know agatha be like you
you're that's chaos
magic wanda and that makes you the
scarlet witch i'll be
best of hitting it the same way you go
through your favorite album and play the
tunes
that you like i've been doing that with
this show forever and that has
everything to do with the directorial
hand behind it give it up ladies and
gentlemen for our guest tonight the
great matt shachman
hello hello sir welcome
and congratulations i told matt before
he came on the show tonight i was like
good lord prepare to be overblown
because
it's nothing but [ __ ] love for this
uh just to give credit how we got here
uh jeremy sempser who i was lucky enough
to work with on
on the cw shows up north when i did
flash and supergirl
he's a storyboard artist and you know
whenever they're like you gotta sit down
with jeremy and do storyboards i said
all right
so i sit down with jeremy and be like
draw whatever you want man i'll just
shoot that he goes what are you kidding
me i was like yeah i mean that's how
go ahead just draw some [ __ ] i was like
i know got no vision if it were up to me
we wouldn't be doing this anyway so you
might as well draw some [ __ ]
jeremy simpson if you look at my
episodes of of uh
supergirl and flash the action sequence
is like
i hand it to him everyone a while i have
changed something to make it work in the
real world and stuff
but he is such a great eye for [ __ ]
storytelling particularly in that genre
i was more than happy to be like do you
think and so he told me
at one point years ago he's like i got a
buddy man i just did storyboards for
[ __ ] game of thrones
i said what how the [ __ ] do you do it
for game of thrones he's like i know a
guy who directed some episodes and [ __ ]
you're that guy isn't that right i'm
that guy
yeah what which episodes there were two
what episodes of
of game of thrones did you direct uh two
in season seven
uh one called spoils of war where um
daenerys attacks the lannister army
they're trying to bring back the spoils
from highgarden
and uh sort of the first big dragon
battle in the show and she destroys
uh the entire army and takes uh the
tarly's captive
and then i did the one after that called
eastwatch which uh sort of sets up their
trip north
um they shoot them do they shoot them in
like uh
like what do they call that like the
you're shooting
is that why you did two or you did one
and then wound up doing another one
where they're close together
i did them together but they did all the
directors on that show were there at the
same time so we would start prep
i think i started prep in july and i
finished at the end of february or
something like that
and so we would shoot bits and pieces of
multiple episodes throughout the whole
time
and they had two to three units going
and that was a huge enterprise but yeah
you could work
six days a week you could work two days
a week so depending on your
your show what you were doing now for
those unfamiliar let me just walk them
through
uh your civvy here man because my god
[ __ ] you go way back
2002 is your first directorial credit on
once and again
yeah yeah coming out of film school how
do you get that job
uh great question no because of ed zwick
and marshall herskovitz who are great
filmmakers producers directors creators
and i was running a tiny small theater
in los angeles on pico boulevard that i
had started called the black dahlia
theater
we were doing new plays and i did this
play about orson welles and i think
maybe because it was about orson welles
a lot of people in la were interested
they came out and um uh they called me
up the next day on my old answering
machine i was
checking ticket reservations and there
was this message from medtowick saying i
loved you play
come on down i'd like to meet with you
so i met with ed and marshall and
i ended up shadowing on that show
observing sort of seeing how things
worked
and that was my film school that was
they were my film school basically ed
marshall
and they gave me an episode of that show
uh right towards the end of it right
before it went down
and then i um and then i went and i i
shadowed ed on the last samurai right
after that and hung around and saw them
put together a big movie which by the
time i was doing game of thrones a
decade later
was hugely valuable because i had seen
horse charges and all that stuff done
before
um so i learned a lot from from those
guys especially ed yeah
when i was i was wondering because
looking at your at your resume it's like
oh there's a lot of like
there's a whole mess of it's always
sunny in philadelphia's
and that seems like the the trajectory
from that to dragon battles
seems particularly difficult to mount
but clearly from the jump like you were
you had some mentors who knew how to get
that done this is my take on it and you
know i'm sure matt's gonna not gonna
blow his own horn but my experience in
the world of television very limited
mark but i've seen
a bit here there um there are directors
journeyman directors who go throughout
this industry and do a lot of things and
whatnot uh and a lot of tv directing
episodic directing
the only reason you work as much as this
cat has worked is because
people like the work and they like being
around that director otherwise you don't
have listen to this list of shows kids
ready
you got once again still life oliver
bean three episodes remember that
summerland judging amy
huff one tree hill you're like the force
[ __ ] gump
of tv of the last 20 years bro austin
legal
six feet under which six feet under did
you do towards the end the one where uh
peter krause's character nate has a
stroke
an arm arm norm norman arm and he falls
down
yeah oh man that's like a lifetime ago
too inconceivable
kitchen confidential how do you direct
kitchen confidential
bradley cooper man before he became the
world's biggest star yeah he was the
story of that show it was great it was
based on the membership
that's right uh ever would windfall
men in trees you did four episodes ever
would yeah
you worked out everybody hates chris two
episodes of that what about brian the
riches the nine
brothers and sisters three episodes
whose show is that is that berlanti or
no
yeah he came in yeah it was started out
with john robin bates who created it and
then berlanti came in and joined up with
him
ugly betty three episodes hung which
episode of hung did you do i love the
one with the big dick
it was a basketball game if i remember
right
ago yeah uh weeds chuck
children's hospital i [ __ ] love man i
mean because
you know it's one thing to do an
hour-long drama children's hospital is
like you know
[ __ ] bizarre short frame storytelling
as well so you mastered that as well
the good guys outsourced breaking in
happy endings
house he did five episodes what's that
guy like
oh he's brilliant yeah fantastic guy
everyone seems to like him new girl
raising hope mad men which mad men did
you do
you know one that divided people it was
when the show ended it was like
equally on the list of everyone's
favorite episode and also everyone's
most hated episode
um it's called mystery date it's where
draper has like a
he has like a he's having a fever dream
and he murders
machinamic and like shoves her under the
bed
um it's a bit of a horror story horror
film type yeah i remember that episode
huge uh gcb psych you did five episodes
cup bank fargo which season you did two
episodes first first season in the last
two
yeah hey man revenge i watched all that
my wife loved that four episodes
grace and frankie man what were they
like they were great oh yeah huge heroes
of mine and you know martin sheen
also too sam waterston everybody in that
show was great
is there a different curve with when
when you have a cast that's like over
70 and [ __ ] like do you can you work at
the same pace that you normally do
oh my god yeah you got to work hard to
keep up with jane fonda man she is the
hardest working person in showbiz making
sure that she's a better teammate
yeah you're the worst the good wife six
episodes
uh american gothic it's always sunny as
mark mentioned but this is the number
ready
43 episodes did you do them all
essentially god no that is the longest
running
live-action comedy in history now season
14
so i have done a lot of them but not not
even
how early did you get in with them uh
season three
[ __ ] a man okay and then how as mark
mentions how do you go from [ __ ]
sunny
to game of thrones where's that
connection actually
very direct in a strange way um
i i had met david benioff in about 2007
because he was producing a western that
i was attached to direct
so westerns there was a big my set piece
in game of thrones was
basically a big western battle and so we
had already
talked about material like that and i
knew and liked him a lot and
that movie almost happened it was kind
of a heartbreaker it had james mcavoy
attached
uh right after atonement and it was for
focus under sheamus it was right at the
sort of
high point of what focus was doing
really great movies and i was so excited
and i kind of knew
gosh if this thing goes down it would be
heartbroken forever and uh mcavoy
uh we got him on a horse to train
because it's a western and it turns out
he had a massive anaphylactic reaction
to the horse he was allergic to horses
and um i'm allergic to everything i was
like
do not drop out of this movie allow me
to find you
some way to do this so i searched the
world and i found
this thing called a bash cure curly
horse which is basically looks like a my
little pony for half the year and then a
real horse the other half of the year
and it's hypoallergenic so i was like
i'm gonna get
james mcavoy on this horse we arranged
it it was in london
um everything went great for an hour and
then the owner of the horse was like
these horses are amazing just go ahead
rub your face in its mane go ahead rub
your face in its mane
and james rubbed his face in the main
and then i got a you know picture of him
his eyes all swollen
up being like sorry and the movie went
down anyway so i met benny off that way
i i've known him over the years
um so proud of him and what he created
but he was really good friends with the
creators if it's always sunny
in philadelphia especially rob mcelini
and he ended up coming and doing a cameo
for us on sunny playing uh both of them
actually benny off and weiss did uh
cameos in this episode about a water
park
and i got to reconnect with them it was
great and then um you know they
just at that time were looking for a
director and happened to be something
that was similar material to
to stake planes and and the sunny guys
were like you should hire matt
and so it ended up working out okay and
um
and then we pranked uh rob mcelhaney
really hard during
game of thrones that year where rob was
checking in how's matt doing
and benny off was like it's rough i mean
i mean
uh any advice on how to work with him
like
it just just may just started telling
this horrible story about how he was
failing and rob was freaking out and
trying to call me
and um anyway he'll never forgive me for
that
but um but that's how i ended up there
yeah amazing man the uh
what let me ask you though in terms of
with that that would be the most
expensive thing you'd ever shot at that
point
right without a doubt yeah was it
intimidating that aspect of it it's one
thing to shoot like you know i'm sure
it's not nope the it's always sunny
budget probably nothing to sneeze at but
i would have a tiny tiny tiny tiny yeah
i need i
imagine game of thrones is like quantum
leap forward was there
fear were you trepidatious at all you
know i was just so
excited to be there i loved that show up
until that point
um i was uh thrilled to be a part of it
and the script was amazing and
those guys are amazing the whole crew
there was fantastic so it was just a
pleasure you know and i guess i was
i'm not smart enough to be afraid so i
just went at it with passion
and excitement and just trying to make
the best story i could so i would
imagine
like when you're talented there is no
fear whatsoever um all right so you got
billions you did an episode strange
angel the boys which
which boys episode you do number two the
one the second one it's uh
this guy transparent or translucent who
are
we were overlapping he was finishing
that up yep [ __ ] hey man
uh then succession which succession
episode you do
this last season the second season it's
called our justice they go to a kind of
uh you know rich person getaway kind of
yeah right it's a really good episode
with the comic and stuff
yeah episode of the great and then nine
episodes of wanda vision so take us into
that where
how does one get a job and obviously not
a tutorial but how
when did it happen what how did when
when were you involved in the process
did you like the rest of us first hear
about wanda vision
or were you involved from the moment
somebody said that word
great question you know it's what i had
been away
from my family from my newborn daughter
to do game of thrones was huge
opportunity and i've gone away and i
the one thing i was sort of afraid of
was uh was it worth it to have left my
wife and daughter for all this time and
i was
worried about how people would receive
the episode um because the fans of game
of thrones were ferocious and
and everyone watched at the same time
and my wife was like um
you know what would make it worth it for
you because i was frightened that it
wouldn't have been worth it if you know
people didn't like it i said well i
don't know if kevin feige calls tomorrow
it'll be worth it and he didn't call the
next day but i think it was a few days
later that i got this you know
call to go in and meet with him so that
was awesome and i got a chance to meet
with him and some of the other
amazing leadership over there at marvel
and then they brought me in on one
project after that sort of pitch on
before
one division came around and then i came
in i first
the first meeting is just it was a
general like hey let your work come in
and let's talk and see if there's
something
exactly yeah he had seen the game of
thrones episode and it was just a chat
just a general meeting um not about a
job in
specific and then i did end up doing
sort of uh one round of pitching on
another project to theirs and uh and
then i did i got invited to come in and
pitch on wandavision i'd heard vaguely
that these disney plush shows were
coming
i didn't really know much about them i
knew there was a loki show i knew there
was a
show with wanda and vision and they said
yeah you're going in for the the wanda
and vision show
and i didn't know i mean i liked those
characters a lot but they've only had
about 10 minutes of screen time together
and um i'm a big comic fan but i hadn't
been focused on those issues unlike you
i didn't i didn't get those issues when
i was a kid out
um so i came in sort of a bit of an open
book on it
and um jack schaefer who's the head
writer mary lovanos who was the producer
from marvel
they had already been working for a
little bit kind of starting to break the
story and figure out what the
what the world was going to look like
and they pitched me essentially this
idea the hybrid of
of sitcom um and really telling the
story about loss
and grief which is what they had already
come up with um and i was so taken with
it it was one of the most amazing things
um that i had been pitched or heard
about and i was sort of desperate to be
a part of it so
i went through the process with them and
with kevin and the rest of them and
eventually got the gig
but it's a strange thing because you
talked about my resume which is you know
um a weird hodgepodge and in this
business you usually have very narrow
lanes like if you're a guy who does
house you do shows like that you know
and if you do comedies you do comedies
um i come from theater so i never i
wasn't smart enough again to know that
i couldn't do lots of different things
so i was trying to always work on
different shows and so it allowed me to
do
uh comedies and dramas and procedurals
and action and all that along the way
but now that we're in the streaming
world where um
shows by their nature are so
they draw from different tones and
genres and styles and that's what makes
it so interesting right now you
mentioned
succession a show that's a drama but
it's written by
very funny people um and that's what
makes it so wonderful
um so uh the fact that i have done all
these different things all of a sudden
especially
the show like one division that's about
sitcoms and i used to be a child actor i
grew up on sitcoms and
and so i i had that experience wait wait
wait what
yeah yes you missed that part of my of
my imdb that i guess
so what did you what were you on like
all the 80 shows
you know i was on webster and different
strokes and facts of life
and i was a regular on this show for
three years there was a spin-off of
growing pains called just the ten of us
and um so i was on that was a tjf friday
night show
um right after god yes you are look at
this you were in the [ __ ] facts of
life
yeah i was what season take the good
and the bad they did yeah yeah but what
what
did you play what season uh you know i
can't remember what season it was um
it was that nancy was dating her
photography
professor and i was his kid and it was
getting way too serious because he had a
kid and i was the kid
you were on an episode of highway
haven't you worked with michael landon
yeah now that one no that was the
christmas carol and it ran every year
for like 20 years it was like there i
was tiny tim in a wheelchair you know
the single tier
the whole thing um yeah michael landon
so i started as
as an actor at four years old and i was
in it you know different strokes
night court night court yeah you were on
the set of something and of course
growing pains
webster um and as you mentioned just who
was the star
the male star of just the ten of us who
was the bill kirkenbauer
it was a comic there he is yes yep
still his guy oh my god man those are
some legendary [ __ ] shows
so while you were working on those shows
and you're a kid were you thinking about
like
hey man there's a job to be done here
that's not in front of the camera did
directing pique your interest
oh yeah for sure it was that annoying
kid that wanted to interview the
camera guys and hang out in the room
when they were calling the show
and asked questions of everybody what
how they did what they did
um i always wanted to do that yeah and
then i got into theater
and and then i kind of went back into tv
through the directing through theaters
we already talked about so so this
job this one division job uh felt like
it was the job that i had been preparing
for my entire life
because i was a sitcom actor i direct
comedies and sitcoms
and i do action and spectacle i do
dramas
uh and this show this crazy wonderful
show
required all of those things did kevin
feige know about
that deep deep back history of yours as
like oh no i spent most of my childhood
on sets just like this
i i eventually yes before i got the job
yeah he figured that out and then
we were doing our virtual press day
because of this weird world that we're
in right now our junket
um julia white was our was our mc for
our press junket
which was great he's an old friend and a
fantastic
human and it was great he he he began
the thing by saying i bet no
you guys don't know that matt and i met
doing the pilot of
good morning miss bliss and we all got
fired and that show got rebranded as
saved by the bell
which was true and i don't think anybody
on the show knew
on one division do that but yeah we were
the original version of saved by the
bell until we were fired
oh my god man so you got tv in your
blood you grew up out here
i did yeah i grew up in ventura an hour
north what do your parents do how did
you wind up as a kid acting
strange story so i dressed up pretty
much exclusively like superheroes
um to the point where my you know
preschool teacher said you can't do that
anymore
it's not healthy or appropriate i was
spidey with like weird creepy masks that
i made myself with sharpie drawn
you know webs on it which you know uh
pre-columbine was still too creepy for
school
and uh i you know but captain america
superman
batman obviously all of those things uh
exclusively i dressed up like them and
my dad is a doctor but he wrote some
books and
he was on a talk show circuit and i
would go with him dressed up as whatever
superhero out of the day and um and i
got discovered at one of those
uh to do a commercial that was the
beginning of of everything yeah i
thought i was super outgoing because i
was
in my world of the imagination i'm not
super outgoing i just need to
eat when i have to be um especially when
i'm wearing a superhero outfit helps
now the um the what was different about
this than most
uh series director giggs is like
generally it seems in series
the max amount of episodes you'll do
back to back is like two or something
like that
but you directed every episode was that
always
the plan going in like one director for
everything make it like one giant
movie that is exactly the plan yeah that
was what
kevin asked at my final meeting he said
can you do all of this and i've done
whole seasons of it's always sunny
um so i said yeah sure yeah one director
can do this it's a big job and
i would probably be not as quick to say
yes if that question were asked me again
um but that was what he wanted to do and
what they at marvel wanted to do
is that they had made a lot of movies
they knew how to make movies this was
their first television show and they
wanted to make it
like a movie so they wanted to have one
director um
and that's what they did for uh for loki
for falcon winter soldier
and for us i think some of the shows
after that they've gone to
maybe two directors splitting it up
three directors splitting it up yeah
now in this world where particularly
with this storyline
um you know there's block shooting is
when they're you know you got a bunch of
episodes of a tv show and
hey we're going to be in the kitchen 96
times shouldn't we do all the kitchen
scenes at once
but with wanda vision since the the era
changed with every episode did you
finish an episode start an episode
finish an episode star
episode or was there was it more fluid
than it would have appeared
a bit of both and it felt like we were
doing a pilot
for every episode that's what i would
imagine like it's you're almost starting
from scratch with the new set and
everything
yeah and we we prioritize the sitcoms so
we
did them earlier or at least the
interiors we started in atlanta when we
were on stage we could build
all those sets and we ended in los
angeles and i wanted to be in la
for some portion of the shooting because
i wanted to shoot on backlots i wanted
to
have that weird fake reel combination
that you get from shooting at
um a big back lot town square
or street so we shot their house which
is on
the warner brothers ranch which i'm sure
you've been to there's a whole little
cul-de-sac of famous sitcom houses there
with bewitched house i dream of genie
partridge family etc
and i really you can't find that out in
the real world it actually takes so much
production design to make
a real street feel that unreal and then
we shot at the disney ranch which is uh
way out in santa clarita for their town
square and a few other things out there
um so most of the sitcom interiors were
done
early in our process because it was the
most
detail-oriented work that we were doing
i mean the action stuff is
detail-oriented of course but
but it was so precise in terms of tone
and style that i really wanted to focus
on that and make sure that we we got
that right up front so we did a whole
sitcom boot camp with the actors
we studied different sitcoms over the
years to figure out
the different approaches um and then we
started with the
50s and then we moved into the 60s and
the 70s and 80s so we did shoot
chronologically on stage for those
interiors
as much as we could why was it important
for you guys to shoot in front of a live
studio audience
because that's what they did uh you know
that was always sort of the governing
principle this is wanda's reality she's
created all of this because of her own
deep love of television the same way
that i love those shows as well and as
you've seen in
the penultimate episode we see how she
would gather with her family so
this is a woman who can create reality
this is the that's what chaos magic is
it's creating something of whole cloth
and so early on those first few episodes
they had to be
perfect and accurate not only just
because i was trying to honor something
but because i was trying to live up to
what wanda maximoff would create which
was
perfection right and so the dick van
dyke
show i love lucy shot in front of a live
studio audience and you can
feel it it's like theater i'm a theater
director too um i run this uh
the geffen playhouse here in los angeles
i do a lot of theater and
it's uh you can feel the energy of it
you can feel that lightning and a bottle
of quality and we went to
lunch with dick van dyke right before we
started shooting just to kind of pick
his brain
i went with kevin feige and we went to
club 33 at disneyland it was like one of
the most unreal most amazing afternoons
of my life
um but i talked to him about it and one
of the things that i learned is that
they pretty much only filmed it
once in front of a studio audience i'm
like i'm sure you guys have been to a
sitcom taping
the the mc is there being like i know
you've seen it 40 times laugh like
you've never seen it before right
they didn't do that they did like a play
they filmed it all the way through they
didn't repeat it
and pretty much what you see of the dick
van dyke show is the one and only time
they put it on like a stage play
opening and closing light all at once
and you can feel that energy you can
feel that spark
and um and they would only do a pickup
if something went terribly wrong
so we tried to do that too as much as we
could obviously once it breaks into kind
of twilight zone
it changes um it was the first thing we
did and it was a great way to bond too
with the actors
was there ever a temptation to because
you have you know the episode where
agatha is sort of tripping through
wanda's memories
and then they reveal that we're on a
stage for some of that stuff and you see
the lights and all that
was ever the temptation to show the
studio audience
you know to be like oh no this was also
part of that there were people here and
here's all the people in the town
sitting in the audience or whatever we
know it's a great
idea we didn't like sort of a zombified
audience sitting there
no i just i loved the idea of of agatha
alone
as the you know the one spectator who
she's been watching wanda through her
her life now up to this point and here
she is watching the one division show
revealing as a set but that is the exact
audience we built that
to be historically accurate brought in
our live audience did the show
and then in the days right after that we
shot that so because we had that set up
now marvel famously [ __ ] like you
know
ndas nobody can know [ __ ] how do you
pull in a studio audience that doesn't
talk
unbelievable that they kept that secret
people signed everything they left their
phones they did all the usual
stuff but we managed to keep that a
secret and not evan peters
so i don't know but somehow that worked
so it wasn't it wasn't like we just
brought friends and family to fill the
audience you actually got real live
people we did we did do a lot of friends
and family we did do friends of friends
and sort of you know there it was it was
not just
random people brought off the street in
atlanta so that didn't help it for sure
um and so you mentioned two names before
jack schaefer and who was the other
mary levanas there and you mentioned
story from both of them but why is one
listed as a writer and one as a producer
but uh
so so the way it works at marvel usually
is that uh
you know kevin had this idea of uh
combining the sitcom
with the story of wanda and recovering
from
losing vision and then that's that gets
handed off to a producer who does
early work sort of kind of looking
through all the comics and kind of
figuring out
what might be the sort of story world
that might be explored
right and then different writers come in
look at that document kind of pitch
on that document their creative take on
it and so jack
pitched her creative take and was hired
as the head writer
and recruited a wonderful room of
amazingly talented
writers she's amazingly talented and a
great leader she brought together this
group of
people and marries in on that too as the
producer so she's a creative producer
you know and that she will have
contributions to story as well as
helping to make the trains run on time
um and remains with the show all the way
through
so jack sort of oversaw that writing and
then jack and i kind of
partnered up um in that process the room
was still kind of going but then i was
able to make
contributions to story work through set
pieces have different ideas and then as
as you start to get to the end of
something like that you inevitably go
back to the beginning and rewrite
through it as well because you're
building a bit of a puzzle you need to
go back and address things you might
have missed or failed to set up
but marvel stuff everything i'm sure in
in the universe like this but especially
marvel stuff is famous for kind of being
constantly
broken again and rebuilt and we did that
process a lot
in service of trying to get to the best
story possible um the rest the writers
in that writer's room ended up sort of
heading off
um before we even started official prep
and then it was
jack and mary and i during prep working
hard together to kind of keep
working on the story and you mentioned
jeremy simser who's a phenomenal
storyboard artist and also there's
two others richard bennett and saman
wilkins who i worked with and so much
storytelling comes from storyboarding
i start to work out what these sequences
are they add ideas we pitch ideas i'll
come up with
15 different versions of how something
could play out and then if we find
something
that works we go back and that's in the
script you know the
episode of the halloween episode but it
used to end just with
her exploding out in the power of red um
and then the next episode would pick up
with vision waking
up in this sword circus and we thought
well no be much more fun to see that
happen
so we developed that out with jeremy and
i developed that out pretty early
in the prep process and then that ends
up being in there so there's a lot of
that kind of
storytelling through visual design that
happens as well
in those early conversations with jack
um
what were the i mean because this show
such a tightrope to walk you know it's
it's got to balance so much spectacle
and emotion
and sort of intimate storytelling in the
grand scale
what were the things that each of you
were concerned about like where did you
think like all right if we don't get
this right this will fail if we don't
get this
right it won't hold up like what were
the what were the things you were
mindful
that you needed to either sidestep or
embrace it's a great question i
i think we always knew that the core
story was the story of wanda
grappling with grief that it was a story
of loss and and
and the flip side of that the other side
of that same coins that is a love story
um it's a great love story between two
amazing characters and their
their love story is so unusual they
couldn't be more different and yet it
feels so right and
and it was about trying to honor that
love story and then
also talk about how you come back from
grief and we've all lost people
and so intentionally we looked at the
you know elizabeth
kubler-ross stages of grief and so you
get to the finale which i think to a lot
of people
you mentioned earlier uh disappointed
about whatever easter eggs i mean
it's inevitable that it would end with
acceptance right it's about someone who
is
who has been in denial about all the
loss she has who's created this sitcom
world where she can't even remember how
she got there
she doesn't allow herself to know how
she got there ends up
accepting it you know a long way she she
does uh she gets angry
of course like we just talked about
expands her hex she bargains
um there's all sorts of you know so we
intentionally structured it that way
and i felt whenever you play with tone
and style
if you have a strong emotional through
line
that's your spine and if you always go
back to that everything else can work
and so
we knew we were playing chicken with
those earlier sitcom episodes we knew
that
we were playing with how long would the
audience hang in there
and there were some that didn't really
want to hang in there maybe they came
back eventually
people said no you should really watch
it um and maybe there were some
grandparents who initially thought it
was charming that when things started to
blow up they were like we're out
but you know what's that venn diagram of
nick at night and marvel it's very
narrow overlap but um i'm in it um i
know jack shafer's in it kevin feige did
it
um so we we wanted to see how far we
could go with that now the pandemic did
kind of
mess with us a little bit because we
originally didn't intend to release the
first three episodes on the same night
which would give it a slightly different
experience um because you would end with
monica as getting getting expelled from
the hex and you would see the sword base
and i think for marvel fans out there
you have a little bit more of a sense of
what's coming
and we were able to release those three
for press but not for the audience just
because we
i mean i finished that finale a couple
weeks ago um we just
literally one more if we tried to you
know release the first three that week
we would not have made the finale and
disney plus didn't want to wait
a week that that reminds me in terms of
shooting so close to airing well
network tv does that and has done that
forever and stuff
but there were moments on this show
where when jimmy wu is working his white
board and he is echoing
the same [ __ ] theories that the
internet was echoing that week
there i was either like they are
incredibly prescient and knew this was
coming
or they are so [ __ ] nimble that they
could like it's just
writing on a whiteboard they could
easily put that in the background
without affecting a shot
were you guys ahead of the story or was
that acknowledging the audience
we were not acknowledging the audience
no not at all we were that was stuff
that we shot in atlanta
that that stuff didn't change at all we
intentionally built the puzzle box and
then wanted sword to be the audience
stand-in that was the meta idea of
binge watching which ult this show came
out weekly so people
were also annoyed they couldn't binge
watch it because weekly but
you know darcy and jimmy they're binge
watching the show and becoming fans and
and watching episode by episode so we
did get lucky
in some ways but then also we we we
didn't get lucky in some ways too
because
uh some of those easter eggs are
absolutely intentional and then some
things like just trying to
to clarify what was monica's plan with
regards to the hex we ended up we did
re-shoot a little thing there
changed some dialogue added the uh
aerospace engineer
which was never an intention on our side
to set up the fantastic
people so careful what you say in a
marvel anything because there is a
corresponding character to that job
yeah employer like it's reed richards
like how
fun is that but then terrifying for the
creator of the show for the director of
the show
and the writers and the producers
because you can see
somebody taking a threat and running
with it and be like no no come back come
back come back
like we're not going over there come
over here he's over here
i find that i mean some of them i find
charming and wonderful
the fan base is so smart and and
knowledgeable that they can create
theories that are better than the ones
that we created in the room of course
but
we're building to this rover set piece
which i have worked my butt off on for
well over a year creating this rover and
all of a sudden everybody
wants to know who's gonna meet her there
and i know it's going to be this
wonderful
actress who's playing you know major
goodner and
uh it's not going to be reed richards
and i want people to be interested in
what is the origin story of a different
character
uh that monica rambo is becoming and uh
and instead we're being distracted by
somebody else so yeah the director
for producer in me is like oh don't run
with that one um
because i i didn't want the focus to
shift from what was
important is the story of of monica
traveling through that axe
now of course like marvel famously all
over their talent about like keep your
mouth shut
[ __ ] no spoilers was like
was there a oh i could go out there and
tell them it's not reed richards but
what was the party line they're like
don't say anything
like what was the as a storyteller
i would be wanting to cover my ass and
be like on the internet every day going
it ain't read richard just get that out
of your head now
yeah i mean i didn't correct i did not
do press before
that episode so i i was not in that
position so i'm not sure
um but uh yeah in general it's you know
let things go don't address the
the rumors is probably better because uh
folks will see the episode and they'll
get their answers anyway
uh but there was another one too that
was funny uh wanda says kick ass
in the halloween episode and everyone's
like oh my gosh some people love that
joke some people thought that i think
one of the reviewers was like oh lame
too far
you know because because evan peters and
aaron taylor johnson are both kick-ass
together
not an intended kick-ass the movie joke
at all like
the little kid says kick ass there was
no scripted response
we were improvising we wanted to set up
the the brother was being a bad
influence
and lizzie was just like kick ass it was
funny and we kept it
and it was absolutely not an intentional
thing so
there are a few of those and then
there's a lot that are intentional too
so can i tell you my favorite
sure my favorite easter egg and it's
it's not a
story thing is it a plot thing it's a
tone thing it's
you know i watch sea beams glitter in
the dark neither 10 house or gate
all these moments will be lost in time
like tears in the ring
i was like oh that's wonderful the fact
that the marquee has
tan house of gate on it and the idea of
an artificial person who's about to die
who's wrestling with the fact that his
memories are going to
potentially be lost forever i was like
that that that i like like i i don't
necessarily want to go down the rabbit
hole of like who's that person supposed
to be
and what cavity was supposed to get but
it's the
here's a thing that's just resonant to
the story we're telling
was that your idea do you put ten how's
the gate on there or was that the
writers was that the
mark mark worthington the production
designer and i put that up there
yeah um yeah i'm glad you got that
that's one of my favorite scenes in
movies
like tears and rain time to die yeah
can't beat that
that was an incredibly subtle blade
runner reference as opposed to the very
overt
wizard of oz references um
which were wonderful and made me
appreciate the wizard of oz all over
again in many weird ways because we were
dealing
with a witchcraft story as well which
was kind of dope and whatnot
the um when when you were um
when you sit down to direct the first
episode
did you have all nine scripts by that
point
no i mean we did have a rough version of
all nine scripts but
they were not accurate to what we ended
up shooting
the scripts it was very much like normal
tv
then well yeah things were constantly
changing and
getting re-broken story was changing
especially a lot of the real world stuff
and the finale
um there was a lot of of experimentation
going on and sort of trying different
things out
um we also at one point had 10 episodes
planned and we ended up collapsing a
couple
you know just to to to make the rhythm
feel a little bit better
um but yeah they constantly changed and
then of course once we we wrapped in
atlanta the pandemic hit and we ended up
having
months off so then further changes
happened during that we were doing
post-production
and then ideas would come up and little
changes would happen as a result because
i think i saw one in the series finale
uh it's her line when she's like i don't
understand this power
but i will there was a look of it that
made that it looked different than the
two other shots
and it looked like a digital ricoh reca
recomposition or whatever
and it looked like you guys were like oh
[ __ ] we got a
nobody referenced this we have to
reference it was i wrong or did you
shoot that on the day or what
that is something we we shot and added
later you're right yeah yeah and that's
so and that that but just like tv tv
does that and also movies they do that
like marvel movies
it's not like they're like this is the
script the script is [ __ ] locked and
you
you adhere to it we know from end game
that the greatest
[ __ ] moment in the movie of him gone
and i am iron man
came months later courtesy of the editor
who was like you know what he should
have said and then marvel's got enough
money and enough balls to be like well
then that's what he will
say and stuff so it's nice to know that
like even an
entity as well-oiled machine as marvel
still is limber enough to like oh let's
let's we can change this we can move
this we can move this
yeah i think marvel i love the pursuit
of excellence that they have they're
lovely wonderful people they're super
supportive
of their filmmakers we had a great time
working there
all of us jack and myself and the actors
everybody
um but they will do like whatever needs
to be done to
make it even one percent better if they
can you know if time allows and so
we were working up right to the very end
until disney plus was like we
if you don't give it to us now we cannot
get it on the air in time
uh and that's that's great because i
think ultimately that's what
audience deserves you know the best you
can deliver
um speaking of the actors you know what
what were the things that elizabeth
olsen and paul bettany
were most concerned with getting right
you know what was there
what were they trying to calibrate as
they went on because i can imagine that
this
again you're playing multiple time
periods multiple aspect ratios multiple
different versions of these characters
where were they
most concerned about finding their way
back to
they understand those characters really
well and i think that their
their chemistry on screen is kind of
undeniable the
way those characters fit together is a
testament to them
both as individual performers but also
the magic that seems to be happening
when they're together
every time um the emotional through line
was super clear
i mean when i first sat down with lizzie
to talk about the show
the thing that she's always loved so
much about wanda as a character
is that she has lost so much arguably
more than
most in the mcu certainly in the comics
um her parents her mother
i mean her parents her brother her the
love of her life
um she's fragile her sort of grip on
reality
is is tenuous at best at times right
she's as close to kind of mental illness
as you get in the comics and
and lizzy cares so much about this
character in paul about vision 2.
um that that part of it was was really
important to all of us
um very important to lizzy very
important to paul and i think very clear
the part that was that needed um
experimentation and i think that they're
most concerned about is obviously the
sitcom stuff where you're taking these
characters that you've seen in the
marvel universe and you're putting them
into very specific very bizarre boxes
um and they're amazing and we have
so much fun rehearsing and and and doing
research and they're both
excellent at doing homework and
preparing and bringing so much to the
table
and then it was just about finding where
that line was what's too big what's too
small
and i do a lot of things that play
around with tone and so i enjoy that a
lot and i
i think it's just an opportunity to play
really and then when you get into the
editing room if you have
options that's when you can sort of tell
the forest from the trees and that's
when you can say oh we can push this
moment this moment could be sillier but
thank god we have this moment that's
much more grounded that reminds us of
the
the
real connection and so it was about
playing with that and playing with sort
of what is comedy over time because
comedy changes
so much um so they were just you know
they were familiar characters in
very unfamiliar environments they
deserve uh
all the emmys i mean everybody worked on
the show if you guys don't get
at least nominated if not win a [ __ ]
bunch of ten
because it was absolute [ __ ] triumph
and their performances as well
you gotta remember this poor guy betany
paul lovely human being he's acting
under a pound of [ __ ] makeup all the
time
you know ridiculous he's gotta you gotta
you gotta uh project through like you
know a clown face essentially and make
you [ __ ] care and he's been doing it
with this character for a while but
in this series they got to pull the
taffy man the two of them
together have been wonderful and they're
small bits together in the movies but
here they got to enjoy each other's
company
really act one another pull out the best
in one another
emotions running high whenever they were
on set and boy did they honor those
characters you want to talk about two
people
that are playing it straight man they're
not like goofing on it
there's nothing but respect and love
they seem to have for the
torches that they're carrying which
means a lot to a fan base that
grew up these characters and or just
love these characters
you were telling a story that
dovetails off of many stories that were
told but like
essentially an endgame sequel which is
like talk about the [ __ ] pressure
right like one of the greatest
entertainments of all time and they're
like
what's the sequel and you're like
wondering i'm doing it
god be [ __ ] terrifying did you also
have to while you're making
the thing um since marvel is what it is
there's another thing that's coming down
the road i.e
multiverse of madness so while you're
telling your story in the present
do you also have to make sure that you
hook up with the story in the future as
well
to a degree yes but what's lovely about
marvel
and i've said this to a few folks who've
asked that question is
it feels like a it feels like a rely
relay race you know where you someone
hands you the baton and you run with it
and then you hand that baton off to the
next one it's not like you're
reverse engineering your product to fit
something that
that's that's more important or has been
already established down the road
one division was the focus while we were
making it and choices that we were
making
were then handed off to other films um
the way we decided to describe monica's
powers all that stuff
it will continue on into captain marvel
2. so you do get a chance to
to kind of arrange the furniture well
you've got control of the set and then
it moves on but we did talk definitely
to the filmmakers for
both of the the movies that we sort of
more directly hand off to
um uh dr strange their story room was
right around the corner from our prep
office so we talked quite a bit
uh and then later once we were nearing
the end of our photography
and and strange was really getting close
to starting i talked to
sam raimi a couple of times and we did
our our art department spoke and we
wanted to make sure there was a seamless
handoff for sure
let's talk about the outfit so you know
this is
obviously the outfit will go on for a
few movies and stuff
how much say does the director have in
like
yeah that's what the vision that's what
the scarlet witch is going to look like
for all time definitely has to say for
sure we worked with uh
andy park who's in their visual
development department
and they're fabulous and lots of
different versions of
of wanda outfits and white vision and
agatha
all that stuff was sort of coming out of
their department
and we would get together with kevin and
and uh victoria alonso
and louis to desposito the marvel
leadership and we would discuss it
and sort of tear it apart and and
rebuild it
and yeah you know eventually we all got
to uh something that we really loved and
we tried it on you know it's also
translating something from a concept
design to an actual
um costume on an actor takes some time
as well and
you know trying to make sure that it
works and it can move and it
it feels good in motion too not just in
a static frame
is tricky and then the crown you know
because the crown is
is awesome and the question of how big
do you how big is that crown
because it's very very big in the comics
and so how big you know how big can you
go um and we went pretty big
we didn't go we didn't go 100 full huge
ground but
i'm pretty i'm pretty happy with where
we ended up but you did you did give us
100 huge crown in the halloween episode
which is like what
that was the most any of us thought we
were gonna get
of of wanda's headpiece like oh that's
you know that how funny it's cheeky and
they get to do it and so
i i think it was a wonderful bait and
switch because it completely
completely threw me off the scent so
much so that i would never have
suspected what was coming was like
oh no she's going to be in the outfit
not only she's going to be in the outfit
but she's going to adopt the name as
well i loved how you threw away some
line with hayward where he was just like
does she have one of those names or
whatever
establishing like no she has no name so
that when it happens at the end of this
be [ __ ] ready i do want to talk about
hayward real quick and as much as
uh you know the whole internet was like
he's got to be mephisto
he's got to be some evil marvel guy
everyone was mephisto
everybody was yeah i point out that like
this guy he don't need to be mephisto to
be an evil marvel guy
he was literally gonna shoot two
children in the street
pulled out a gun and was gonna shoot two
[ __ ] kids i'm like
that's that's as villainous as it gets
he doesn't secretly have to be mepisto
[ __ ] dude man um that sequence was
wonderful though watching
uh monica use their powers for the first
time and whatnot um
that you know is our first
representation of
photon or whatever the character
whichever direction they take
monica in in the comics she has been
captain marvel she's had a few names and
stuff
yeah in that something like that in as
much as like okay we're gonna show her
powers for the first time like how much
of that is like uh okay matt this is how
it's gonna be done
and how much of it is like this is what
i would like to do because you're
playing with
toys that aren't yours and it's like and
knowing going forward this toy is going
to be someplace else
if you're establishing a power and a
look of a power how much authorship does
the director have
in in this world 100 there much like
what i was saying
you know even though she's going to go
play a major role in a film to come
she was she belonged to one division and
so we got to sort of figure out how to
express
that what it would look like uh her
transformation
uh scene in in episode seven and then
also how
uh her powers would express over the
next couple of episodes
um and then yeah we built and rebuilt so
many different versions of
how she would function in the finale she
had
in some versions much bigger role to
play in the kind of larger
fight that was happening but ultimately
the
structure of the show felt like it
needed to be agatha and wanda
and obviously vision and white vision
and
we wanted to make sure that we had a
moment where monica leveled up in a way
but left room for there to you know
there's a lot of story left to tell
about that character
how um how sad are you or is this not
the case at all
but you know do you want to keep playing
with these toys
you know like you you've invested so
much time and passion and energy into it
you know like i understand that at least
from
from you know kevin feige that he
currently doesn't have an idea or
formation for
for one division season two the the
natural follow of this story is
is doctor strange too but like do you
want to stay in this arena do you want
to keep on monkeying with these toys is
there another marvel story you want to
tell
is this an ecosystem that you're happy
in
you were talking to the guy who dressed
up like spider-man
by that stage intervention so i think
you know the answer
i mean i love i love comics i grew up
being a huge
marvel dc fan um you know i love
i love the mcu i was there front row for
iron man
and opening day and i'll i've been there
for all the films
ever since and they're a great place to
work so i mean they're
wonderful filmmakers as i said they're
super supportive and yet they're also
totally focused on excellence which i
love um i had the best time and i would
absolutely come back um i don't you know
one division season two isn't
something that is being planned right
now things can change obviously
it is the marvel universe things uh you
know definitely their surprises ahead
um but we were trying to tell a very
complete story over those nine episodes
and um we did reach a i think a
satisfying conclusion hopefully or you
know an emotional conclusion to that
story
hard to imagine how we would come back
in a season two with that
unique structure in terms of sitcom and
the story of wanda and vision
but i do think everything in the mcu
leads to other things so
you know wanda continues into doctor
strange
monica continues into captain marvel and
where they go from there and how they
end up
maybe back on disney plus at some point
who knows but you know the future is
exciting
i would like a jimmy wu show please yeah
can you talk to the people about the
jimmy wu hour
absolutely or maybe just a ralph boner
show seeing him like going auditions and
like just trying to make it
you know was boner was a sitcom
reference too wasn't it because
when growing pains like there was a kid
named or something like that
that's a reference to yeah i was on
growing pain so yeah that's a reference
to boner yeah um the uh
where you know we saw agatha harkness
get her introduction into the marvel
cinematic universe of course we saw
uh vision wanda aka the scarlet witch we
saw
speed and and wiccan we saw
um uh uh monica rambo
um we've you know jimmy wu came back
darcy came back were there any marvel
characters that you guys at the
beginning were like
these two and then just couldn't make
the cut
not really it's such a full chess board
as it is and
um getting all of those sort of chess
pieces to
go where they needed to go and that
finale was hard enough i think any more
on the on the chessboard would have been
tough it was really about it was about
wanda and vision the whole time
you know and uh i think the introduction
of of
white vision at the end uh was a really
wonderful way to talk about
um it's all it's the same theme of loss
you know
are you still the thing that i love you
know you can't go home again this is
this is her vision but it's not her
vision um and then this vision that she
created that has no real body
is that real you know what who is the
real vision was sort of one of the
biggest questions of
of the finale um and part of her
necessary journey for
being able to accept her loss and move
on
what was the uh favor your favorite
thing to shoot of all nine episodes the
one where you were like oh my god but
like that's
career oh i mean easily every part of
the day
that we shot agatha all along was my
favorite part
um where we would be in the middle of
doing some you know live audience taping
day or whatever they'd all leave and
then we'd do
some wacky thing for agatha alonso
because we had to do it for every period
so we would do it when we had the sets
up and the
costumes or whatever and just being able
to hang around with catherine hahn being
silly is super fun
and uh and that was the highlight of the
day for sure um she's i haven't i've
interviewed her before and i think i was
on an episode of uh
at midnight with her lovely lovely like
warm funny human being and stuff and
genuinely real
um was she like part of the project when
you came in or were you somebody like
were you
essential in her casting yeah no she
wasn't she wasn't there we we cast her
uh we were always like how we want
someone like katherine han you know
we just want someone like catherine han
and we could you know she was she was
definitely
at the top of our list but she was i
think she was busy
mrs fletcher i can't remember what it
was you know and then there was that one
day as we were debating
you know who we should make an offer to
like you know
she's available now we're like what you
know and uh and she'd also she'd come in
just recently for a general meeting at
marvel to meet with kevin and lou and
and so it just goes it just worked out
that this
you know the the rabbit we had been
chasing no pun intended with uh with her
rabbit
was uh was right there all of a sudden
available and so that that worked out
great
victory and lou are two people you
mentioned before i saw victoria speak
at a kid's film school like uh
convocation or graduation and she was
absolutely wonderful like you know and i
i fancied myself a good public speaker
so i remember sitting down and being
like i gotta wait till this marvel
ladies done and then i get to go
and she had me captured and she also
captured all the kids imagination
as well really great uh speaker know
lou at all who and i honestly can't say
i know her i just saw her speak
who are these two figures we always talk
about kevin feige but who are
victoria and lou great question and so
well deserved to draw attention to both
of them um
the the leadership at marvel really is
the trio
of of kevin lew and victoria victoria
isn't they're all involved in everything
they'll be in meetings to talk about
what will the scarlet witch look like
they'll read scripts they'll
um be involved in all of the art
department stuff that we're doing and
they'll weigh in on casting
but that but victoria primarily is in
charge of handling post-production
visual effects that you know lou
primarily is overseeing production and
sort of
so both of them have those two things um
service
as their chief oversight and kevin is
working
obviously on all steps of those things
and he's working on scripts and casting
as well as overseeing day-to-day stuff
and looking at cuts and they all
weigh in on editorial as well so when i
would do editorial reviews it would be
for the three of them and get their
notes
um uh as we went along so the three of
them really are the
the engine that makes marvel work and
kevin being the guy we we
reference uh all the time it sounds like
from your description of the process
he was not omnipresent but involved
every step of the way how often do you
see him
once you get into i'm sure in in pre
that a lot but once you get into
production how often do you see kevin
quite a bit he's amazing i have no idea
how he does all the things he does i
mean he
i felt that he was totally focused 100
of the time
on one division and yet he was also
doing 5 000 other shows and each one of
those filmmakers felt he was focused on
their project with the same degree of
focus sometimes i felt like he knew my
scripts better than i did which i don't
know how you do that
but he was and the other thing about him
is he's always incredibly calm
you know he's never frazzled even though
he's doing a million things and he's
able to be completely focused
which is wonderful and open you can you
know send him a script you can
send him a scene you can and he will
take it in and have
clear great comments on it it's the it
really is
sort of a strange combination of show
runner and studio head
and people asking who was the show
runner of wanda vision i mean it wasn't
me and it wasn't jack like we both kind
of shared she
you know oversaw the the writing portion
we kind of met in the middle on the prep
and the casting and all that and then i
kind of ran the production and the post
part of it but ultimately along the way
our chief filter for every step of that
was kevin so kevin really is the
showrunner of one division he's the
ultimate
sort of person to say if there's a
decision to be made which way to go
and the ultimate sort of note on
something but it's also
uh going through victoria and lou as
well getting their notes
um so yeah it's a wonderful process i
have to say and i think it does
help it and be the best that it can be
is directing another full-on season of
tv a thing that you're looking for
i'd be interested in it i would if it's
the right story
it's fun to be able to be with things
like you mentioned the great i did the
pilot to the great which was a lot of
fun again a really
that's a fun shot that was a really fun
show super fun show
hard tone to get right casting was great
really fun to build that world
i did the pilot of that yeah you had to
set that tone for those that don't
follow this kind of thing closely
you know uh matt has come as we've
listed a bunch of his credits prior to
wanda vision
he has directed on a bunch of shows but
um
generally speaking if you come into a
show like you know season seven of game
of thrones
style is set the the tableau is a
tableau is set so you're pretty much
making their show as best as you can you
know bring you trying to elevate it but
you got to shoot their [ __ ] show if
you shoot a pilot of something
you set the tone essentially you're the
everyone who directs after you is in one
way or another
following the tone that you have to set
now in the case of wanda vision
matt got to direct every episode so the
tone was his throughout
but generally speaking on a tv show
pilot director sets the tone [ __ ] off
maybe comes back a year later and [ __ ]
like that
and in the process everybody has made
not carbon copies but like
versions of a show that look very much
like what was established by the pilot
director
which is a really fun job i love doing
that it's you know i do a lot of theater
as i mentioned it's like you know when
you
launch a new play out in the world it's
really fun to help it you know
get born um but something like wanda
where you get to be there for the
you know the birth of it the beginning
the middle and the end of it you see it
all the way through
it's super satisfying and i i would you
know love to do a big movie too and
that's really fun but
how much can you do in two hours versus
what we were able to do in six hours
we're telling a really wonderful
story um and it felt like just the right
time i'm loving this
idea of eight nine ten episodes it's
perfect and who wants to watch 22
episodes of
law order anymore and also to some
degree who wants to watch two hours
where you gotta save the cat on page 20.
you know
we've got such a limited amount of time
to introduce all your characters and
tell a complete story it feels like
this limited series world is really a
wonderful kind of golden age of
storytelling just enough time but not
too much
is it going to be hard to just like drop
into an episode of like law and order
organized uh shopping and just like here
i am
50 minutes i'm done you got four weeks
out of me i'm bouncing like as opposed
to the
year that you spent in the one division
world yeah two two years now in wanda
for sure beginning to end
um yeah i'm not so much interested in
bopping in these days to just do an
episode here or there
um i think i'd rather try to find uh
those limited series or
films or pilots to do um because it is
just so much more satisfying
it's fun to work on shows that you love
and if it's a show like game of thrones
where it really feels like you're doing
a movie and you're able to make a lot
out of your
episodes even though there is a style
template and there's certain
kind of rules of the universe the
storytelling is so big
that it does require a lot of the
director but yeah just to pop in and do
another episode of law and order is like
yeah i don't know you know there's more
fun things to do
yeah when you direct theater
um it's it's to me has always been a
befuddling process compared to film you
know film you
do it like uh once and you shoot it and
you never have to worry about doing it
again or something like that but a
live show they go on and mount the show
every night but the director is not
there every night so is it essentially
like you
create it you rehearse them you set the
tone
all the rehearsal and then on opening
night you walk away
pretty much yeah i mean the stage
manager is there to make sure that
nothing goes awry
and if things start to get reinvented in
a way that is breaking the rules of what
you built
the stage manager is meant to kind of go
in there and remind the actors hey you
know this is not what we planned
and to keep it in line but that's also
part of the joy of theater is that it
changes every night and people are
reacting to the audience the audience is
making that performance different in a
different way which is super exciting
um but your job as a director in theater
is to
build that experience with your actors
together figure out that
how you can tell the same story with the
same tone the same approach
and build each moment so that it all has
a logic so that
it can repeat every night organically
you know it's nothing's being sort of
shoehorned in the whole story just flows
because that's how you built it
um and that's the challenge of that but
you have four weeks to rehearse it and
build it and then it's
off and hopefully then it that is four
weeks is that a
normal standard play time or pretty much
yeah
yeah it depends you know on broadway
versus summer stock it'll change a
little three or four weeks yeah
and you're still you've obviously you
mentioned before you but now you [ __ ]
work that you had the pico theater of
your own
yeah i [ __ ] run and [ __ ] at the
geffen which for those that don't live
out here it's big playhouse in
in los angeles how much time do you find
like obviously during the course of
shooting one division you can't be doing
any live shows and stuff
how often do you jump back into the
world it seems like your heart's in both
places
definitely yeah and as the artistic
director of theater playoffs i'm
always working on stuff there so reading
scripts
hiring directors working on casting so i
get home from
shooting a long day at wanda and i would
you know open up my laptop in atlanta
and just go to work for three or four
hours you know and i was doing the pilot
to the great i was
working all night you know because of
the time difference um to
you know help with the shows that were
happening at the theater and when i'm
not directing tv
or film stuff then i'm i'm there at the
theater in rehearsal helping stuff out
and then i direct
once every couple of seasons i'll do a
play
i'll tell you man like you got a big
long
dick of a career here with a lot of
[ __ ] work to show for it
and i've seen absolutely some of it and
enjoyed it and stuff but
you know quantum leap forward career
best
with what you've done with wanda vision
i don't just mean that as a guy who
likes marvel stuff
talking about a guy who just loves tv
who loves movies who loves to feel
who loves to look at fake people and
feel real
things for you to be able to pull the
amount of emotion
that you did from me with you know one
guy is a synthesized and
and the other is a broken witch like
baby witch as the broken baby witch
um and watching her become whole again
it was an incredible emotional journey
for the viewer
and a magic trick matt like you know
[ __ ] not everyone could pull that
[ __ ] off like and and if the fact that
you have
worked tonally in all over the place
and then found a project that was like
everything you've ever done
we need that here including your
childhood
acting and sitcoms is breathing rarefied
[ __ ] air but like it's not it's
it's not like uh man he's lucky he got
that gig the right guy got the [ __ ]
gig i don't know
that it would be what it is if you
weren't
an element um congratulations man it's
if one of my favorite things i put it
right there with book of mormon one of
my favorite things ever made
by human beings well bobby lopez who
wrote about thief songs
also made book of mormon so there you go
really
oh yeah it's all it's all because of
bobby so
bobby and he did uh agatha all along in
all those songs so yeah so bobby
and kristen lopez kristen anderson lopez
um
they are they were oscar for frozen
right they're the frozen kids they got
the egot
yes so yeah so they wrote frozen and
coco
um but bobby also wrote on his own he
wrote avenue q
and book of mormon um and uh and then
yeah and then
with his wife who's amazing uh they
wrote all the theme songs for
for one division so he's the secret
sauce did you guys
know when you were doing it that agatha
all along was going to be the jam that
would take off
did not expect it to chart on itunes
when i i was texting han like just
watching it go i was like are you past
bieber
all right like only cardi b can stop you
now
and uh it was amazing to see that happen
i mean i've known bobby since college we
we went to college together
he wrote really awesome scores for
terrible plays that i directed back in
the day
and we haven't had a chance to work
together as proper
adults and when this was happening i
knew that
you know there was no one better than
than the lopez's to be able to do this
so and they loved tv theme songs and
they were
thrilled and they did just a brilliant
job and no i was amazed that agatha all
along took off the way it did but
i'm so happy i'm so happy that it did
were you prepared for the mummification
of one division like it's been bonkers
man like and the things that i didn't
expect like my
favorite thing was people taking vision
in the black turtleneck
and like a giant necklace on him and
he's now vishan
yeah i saw that today some touch of
betany it was so funny um
yeah i loved i loved all the you know i
love the line you know
uh what is grief but love persevering
but but then paul
paul is good at sending uh memes he sent
me one my favorite one was
uh what is beef if not cow persevering
what is cheese if not milk persevering
that's beautiful
right a lot of good ones out there i
mean people are so talented
and creative seeing the tick tock videos
seeing the remixes
it's awesome and an honor and you know
we just had our head
in the sand like ostriches making this
thing never imagining or thinking about
quite what the reaction would be um so
it's it's
so exciting and kind of overwhelming
um what you know as they always say in
this business once you accomplish an
amazing [ __ ] feat that
that can't be achieved by anybody else
and and
you know will stand the test of time um
the first question they always ask is
what are you doing next what are you
going to do after this how do you
[ __ ] follow a bond division
exactly so i should retire right that's
probably what i should do
right stop right at the top man it'll
never be better
i mean [ __ ] but what do you have to keep
going so what do you do
no idea not sure you know it's funny i i
had a whole bunch of stuff planned
for uh what i was gonna do after one
division was done
and then the pandemic hit and all those
other things just kind of
you know went away because of one reason
or another i was going to do the
scottish play which i you don't say the
name because it's cursed with uh one of
the great actress from game of thrones
uh nikolai koster waldow
at the gaffin it was really fun we had
the whole thing planned ready to go
i'd see that oh my god i would totally
see that and they died
and well yeah because you know no
theater somebody say the name
year and a half somebody said the name
didn't they yeah right exactly
and then i was gonna do this amazing
script uh for the russos about the
cambridge analytica scandal
uh the facebook scandal you know they
helped selection
and then you know but but it's a more
modest indie budget
and that's not something you can do
really during covid and then you know
and my schedule was so overwhelmed with
wanda that i couldn't stay with it
so i just kind of been working on one
division so
hard and to the last two until two weeks
ago that i haven't even thought about
what's next so i'm now just taking a
beat and a deep breath and we'll see
it was worth all the time and the effort
you deserve
as much of a break as you want and you
really deserve to cherry-pick
whatever it is you get to do next it
sounds like you got no problem finding
work
and find and more importantly finding
satisfaction in the work that you do
but i gotta i gotta believe you know i'm
i'm certainly not
finger on the pulse in this business but
i've been around long enough to know
that like
he finds [ __ ] heat i can't imagine
you don't get offered the world after
[ __ ] this so rest up
man they're gonna start [ __ ] giving
you the big
[ __ ] jobs and [ __ ] like that um and
you earned it this is wonderful but
i i said it before before you get on
i'll watch this [ __ ]
forever you know same way like when i
[ __ ] get bored or lonely or sad and i
turn to some [ __ ] that makes me feel
good that i've watched my entire life
juan division now joins a very exclusive
list of go-to
instant feels like i i can see myself
just
waking up in the morning with nothing to
do smoking a joint and [ __ ] watching
the highlights just going through every
episode and cherry-picking the [ __ ]
that made me feel like and that's what
it did it made it made you laugh it made
you
cry it just made you feel it was so
[ __ ] human
um so thank you for that man well thank
you i'm a huge fan of yours
you are a huge inspiration to me it's an
honor to be here it really truly is
um can you stick around and answer some
questions from the audience if we make
sure that they're not [ __ ] spoilers
of course yeah no bring it on jump in
instead of me and mark answering
questions i'm sure the kids would
probably much rather
hear uh from matt for heaven's sakes
but you you find some questions jc we
gotta read another ad
oh my god that's right for housekeeping
that's right matt
why are we while we earn some of that
[ __ ] money for our show this ain't
marvel man so we ain't got those [ __ ]
crazy disney bucks we gotta
we gotta pay for our own marvel disney
plus box differences oh my god
and another thing like [ __ ] like
you're the the
magic trick that it takes to have a
disney plus
show that makes people forget that only
last month
luke [ __ ] skywalker showed up on the
mandalorian you know what i'm saying
like you were the first show that had to
follow that [ __ ]
and still you guys stuck the landing and
captured the imagination
hats off well done thank you all right
what are we selling this time around
this is our good folks our good friends
at keeps ladies and gentlemen you know
we watched visio
heaps right indeed we watched vision and
scarlet witch we watched
wanda vision for the last eight nine
weeks and the one thing you can't escape
his vision is bald as [ __ ] he couldn't
do some keeps
could he use keeps if he'd started in in
age of ultron because
that's the pro the the thing about keeps
is you use it right away
and it helps you keep your hair and
stuff if he started an age of ultron he
either had a lush head of hair
today from do not have the ability to
alter your pers your
sort of visage at will you might want to
look at some keeps it offers a
easy stress-free way to keep your hair
convenient virtual doctor consultations
and medications delivered straight to
your door
every few months you don't even have to
leave your house uh
we know keith's been a proud sponsor of
fat man uh beyond for a while now
uh which means that it must be working
uh
you don't get people come back as a
sponsor unless some people are
out there going like i'll try that keeps
so why don't you be like all the people
who've been in our audience so far man
who's given them a shot that afforded us
the opportunity to do yet another
commercial
for the good folks it keeps man how did
they do that mark where do they go they
go to k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash fat man to receive your
first month of treatment
for free and after that treatments start
at just ten dollars per month and
they'll
also offer generic versions of the
medication so that's keeps.com ke
eps.com fat man to get your first month
free
they ain't gonna make you new hair
nobody could do that ladies and
gentlemen but they can't help you keep
the hair that you got for heaven's sakes
man
keeps uh a proud sponsor of fat man
beyond uh if you're trying to hold on to
it
go what's the address one more time mark
keeps.com
fat man thank you keeps uh and thank you
matt for
your childhood actor skills kicked in as
you kept a straight face going what
[ __ ] show is this
why am i sitting through an ad but you
know what we sat through many of your
[ __ ] ads
let's talk about those ads real quick
sure what was the purpose of those ads
i've i've read every theory online from
people
but now i'm going to go right to the
source what was the idea of the ads
i don't want to spoil anybody's fabulous
theories because there are some
amazing theories out there um it was
a way to trickle out some of the bigger
questions of the show history of wanda
of course stark toasters strucker
watches
hydro bath soak lagos and so on
they they also worked thematically as
well the shark
and uh the poor kid on the desert island
um
so up for interpretation of course but
they
they had um the same actors in all of
them
for a reason same idea that everything
was iterated in this world and wanda
just decided those two
lovely townspeople needed to be um cast
permanently in the ads
um and that you know that was that was
pretty much it there's nothing nothing
to do with infinity stones really but uh
yeah
um there was a lot of uh i remember the
internet had me convinced that
they were gonna be wanda's parents when
they finally did the flashback
right and when they weren't i was like
well
go figure the internet's wrong i never
knew that we'd ever see the day that the
internet was incorrect
in with wanda and her parents uh
beautiful
scene in scovie and whatnot but this is
a realized version
of a story we had only heard before
uh in age of ultron what kind of
responsibility is that when you're like
all right now we're actually gonna show
this thing that people have known for a
while
it was all about trying to answer that
question about why sitcoms you know it
was about
what place they had in her life and it
was you know she learned english from
watching them her father was a
bootlegger
trying to make a buck by hustling them
in sokovia
and that as the war rages outside they
find solace as a family huddled together
around a television you know you were
saying i think about
you know this is the your wife is who
you watch tv with you know this is
that's
husband and wife on the couch mirroring
vision and wanda as the kids are down on
the floor watching
it's a scene that we've all had in our
own lives and have seen
uh throughout the history since
television was invented you know as we
all gather around this sort of
modern day fireplace and watch and um
and it happens to be dick van dyke
you know and my favorite episode of dick
van dyke you know i get to pick those
things
and it's the one that is most similar to
one division because it's playing around
with this kind of
crazy twilight zone thing it's all a
dream sequence
um and so it's it's that's the origin
story you know and so it's
how agatha can say uh here
as a baby witch obsessed with sitcoms
with years of therapy out of her
um it's the launching point for the
story the uh it did that moment is
insanely resonant i talked to walt
flannigan my friend
who was on comic book men for years and
stuff like that walter not the biggest
uh beating heart there is you know he's
got a heart but he's generally he don't
he don't cry like me and [ __ ] i don't
think he's ever cried
yeah but you know he big marvel guy uh
going way back particularly classic
marvel
so i hadn't checked in with him i had no
idea if he was watching wanda vision and
so we were talking a couple weeks ago i
was like you watch him
on the vision he goes [ __ ] yeah i was
like you like it he goes i [ __ ] love
it
and so we talked after the one episode
just watched uh
second to last and he hadn't seen it yet
and i was like do me a favor when you're
done
text me i don't care what time it is and
tell me what your favorite moment was
because i was [ __ ] sure
that it was going to be white vision
because like it comes directly from a
[ __ ] comic of west coast avengers
i thought he'd be like oh my god i can't
believe they're doing white vision
and he texted me at like two in the
morning to say wanda watching
dick van dyke with her family was the
the best moment of that show for me and
it's not just because like you know he's
a nick at night guy or whatever [ __ ]
is because like you said we all have
that moment
somewhere in our lives somewhere in our
memories one of the best moments of our
childhood
or gather around a tv set with members
of our family and it don't happen
anymore
like the world doesn't operate that way
anymore people don't consume
television that same way anymore the
the model though of you know here we're
only giving you give you one episode a
week
really push toward that because if they
if you guys dropped eight episodes i
probably would have streamed in my
office and
[ __ ] my wife but instead i watched it
with my wife and she was [ __ ]
dialed in man so yeah
i mean because it was such a love letter
to
classic television going out weekly made
sense and i do think because it
introduced uh wanda in this 50s setting
grandparents were interested people who
had grown up watching those shows in
syndication were interested
and so i've heard many stories wonderful
stories about grandparents
and parents and grandkids all city you
know coming together to watch the show
or because of the pandemic not being
able to be together but
then comparing stories and having
grandkids explain to grandparents who
thor is and what this is and what that
is and um that's lovely you know the
fact that the show has allowed
um different viewers maybe non-marvel
fans to come together
around a story has been really exciting
do you know that going in like do you
is there you know you just we assume
from the outside that
marvel knows everything they're doing in
advance and [ __ ] everything's
calculated and stuff like that
do they know like as you guys are making
it
i bet your family's gonna sit down and
watch this together i bet you it's going
to be a much
multi-generational thing is it designed
to be such or is that just like
wow look at that go figure all right
we'll take it freebie
you know i i a little bit of both you
know certainly it wasn't
it wasn't designed that way it was an
engineer like that want that marvel
wanted to make something that everyone
could watch together
but it is the nature of this story and
the story was
very specific and the fact that it did
embrace older television created an
opportunity there um
and the fact that the earlier episodes
were rated pg allowed
younger kiddos to watch them i'm my
five-year-old
daughter who's watched nothing that has
that i've made
of course really not even succession i
would imagine that's great
five-year-old crowd yeah she loves one
division she
has made me watch the episodes over and
over to the point where i'm like i've
seen this enough i do not want to watch
this
we're listening to the theme songs in
the car so it's wonderful that
uh you know it has appealed to audiences
of all ages but no
it wasn't some nefarious plan um
you know my wife worked at disney
animation forever and i do remember them
saying
um uh movies with an all animal world
sell better in china or whatever so that
was the impetus for zootopia being made
i think a long time ago
um even though that movie is amazing and
it has so much had so much to say when
it came out it did begin with a kind of
reverse
engineering desire but that is not the
case with one division the story was
much more idiosyncratic than that and
i guess it's the field of dreams thing
if you build it they will come hopefully
sidebar what uh disney stuff did your
lady work on
everything she's a genius she worked uh
there
during the the golden age my my daughter
has a credit on moana
because they have production babies
babies that are born during
the so she's right there next to the
rock's daughter i think and lin-manuel's
daughter right
on there or son um and uh
but yeah wreck-it ralph uh frozen
zootopia a bunch of great movies oh my
god
it must be amazing to be your children
like dad working at [ __ ] want a
vision mom's worked at disney
like access to all fun wonderful things
it's great whenever she has questions
about
a movie my wife is able to be like okay
well do you want to facetime with the
director who made that and you can ask
other questions about the old drugs be
friends with your wife because that's
the kind of accident
he would like as well
my daughter has some tough questions
though she was asking some serious
frozen two mythology questions
and stumping them you know
genius um all right jc come on back we
gotta let matt go back to his life and
stuff and i'm sure
there's some cats that want to ask him
some questions you pulled some questions
for yeah i got some questions
uh i really like this one we touched on
it but i think
people kind of want to know more uh
joseph santos
um was asking if you could elaborate a
little bit on
the uh what is grief if not love
persevering
line where did it come from how did it
develop
um how did that uh come from
nothing to be like uh what everybody
was crying and talking about for a week
or two
it's a great question i mean the simple
answer is that it came from
the mind of the writer of that episode
the amazing laura dhani who wrote
a very beautiful elegant simple line to
encapsulate what the entire series was
about
um and it's also it comes after a really
beautiful line as well i think people
forget about the line before about
waves of grief and what it's like for
wanda to experience that loss
how difficult that is and then vision
gives her a key
uh of a way to take her grief and turn
it into something
wonderful and allow her to move forward
and it's how they bond together
and here's this guy who's who's not
human and yet he's more human than the
rest of us he seems to understand
humanity more than any of us
so it's a key to why they fall in love
and i think why did it take off so much
that's something you could never predict
and we did not know when we made this
started making this that it would come
out in the middle of a pandemic where
everyone
will have lost someone um where over
500 000 people have died in this country
alone i think grief and loss is
everywhere
right now so a line that would have had
resonance i think in any year
takes on uh extra special significance
this year
um so that's part of it i think and then
it's also the fact that it's just so
beautifully performed by two amazing
actors
that's that episode is big and it goes
everywhere we're constantly
making crazy cinematic transitions and
then you end up with two actors
on a bed um talking to each other
and that's it that's the show right
there you don't need any bells and
whistles you just need two amazing
performers
bringing that to life um what a great uh
answer but a great question too man um
it and
you're absolutely right like this show
is
a healing soothing bomb you know after
the [ __ ] year that we've had uh you
know i went into it not even thinking
about that i was just delighted
we're seeing wanda vision but now that
you put it like that it's absolutely
true
it was probably as comforting as it was
because it was a [ __ ] warm blanket
after a real
[ __ ] of a year man um i think with
time more people will probably see it
the way
you said it like with some time going on
like oh remember we'll be able to look
back and be like remember how shitty
things were until one division
we did it man we saw the pandemic right
you did you
delivered vaccines to people better than
both administrations
this cured the [ __ ] heart the broken
heart of covet ladies and gentlemen
uh jc come on back give us another
question that was a good one
okay uh don't feel compelled to answer
this
but if i don't ask it everyone in chat
is going to have my head
um everybody wants to know about
fake pietro why bring why bring that
actor back that's
that is the overwhelming question
happening
that's fair some stranger texted me
about it earlier today as well
how do people get your cell phone number
i don't know but they actually launched
a new pirate
what did they write the stranger just
that yeah just out of the blue no idea
who the person is
sent me this tirade like didn't you guys
learn from iron man 3 with the fake
mandarin and
and my first toy takeaway was that was
my favorite part of iron man 3. yes
ben kingsley came out of the bathrooms
like don't go in there i was like i was
this is amazing
um trevor the fake mandarin was
fantastic
playing with expectations turning things
around
is always enjoyable and and i what i
would say to the
to the marvel fan who's a little
disappointed that the x-men didn't show
up or the multiverse didn't show up
um clearly right there is that they're
coming you know they're coming right
you've got a movie called multiverse of
madness you've got
mutants announced at comic-con a year
and a half ago
like they're coming and guess who else
is coming the mandarin is coming he is
also announced as
you know the villain at chengchi so your
patience will be rewarded
um but what we were doing i mean yeah
aaron taylor johnson could have
been there at the door and then i guess
he would have been
the puppet of agatha but we already have
a loved one brought back really from the
dead
in vision right so what's more
interesting like what grief does to us
that we're allowed that we that allows
us to accept
a face that is unfamiliar to us um and
to roll with that as unnerving as it may
seem
because one again this is this is
bargaining right here we are in the
stages of death
stages of grief like she's willing to
bargain with herself in a way to be like
yeah i want my brother back too so i'm
willing to accept that this is not
the face that i remember um and then
you know at the same time it's a sitcom
it's a meta comment you know it's
it's he's been recast he's you know dick
sargent instead of jake your darren
right he's that he's the second
generation becky for that
right but in the end
yes yes and there is a whole great
tradition of that in sitcoms and
to top it all off this is evan peters
he's a great actor he's a brilliant
actor he's so funny and like everybody
else in the show
capable of doing anything from comedy to
drama and everything in between and all
of it at the same time
and to have him show up as uncle jesse
and disrupt this family
i mean these are these are really fun
and at the end you know people would
have been asking us who's ralph
if we hadn't answered that one so we
answered that one he's ralph
you know he's the poor he's the poor guy
at the end of the block that i get the
move did you know
and put some puka beans around his neck
you know so that's what happened
i did not bump into that in the least
like when it
turned out to be nothing but a guy that
she [ __ ] put a spell on
yeah that didn't i was i enjoyed the
[ __ ] mic
drop of the end of that episode of
seeing him at the door
i enjoyed like the next episode of of
izzy isn't he or whatnot i i loved when
she called him fietro a couple episodes
later and stuff
i didn't bump into that at all i'm
telling you i i'm i
i enjoy theories as much as the next
person and whatnot um
i for one i was saying early in the show
earlier in the
run of wanda vision i was like i don't
know why people are saying mephisto
and then at a certain point the internet
had me convinced that
it was going to be mephisto so i was
like i guess i guess it could totally be
mephisto
but there wasn't one like internet
theory or one like oh it could be reed
richards or it could be doctor doom it
could be you know victor vandu
none of that like when credits rolled i
was never like oh they didn't they could
have and they didn't
i was so delighted with the miracle that
the show
[ __ ] was man like you know
so expectation you get the better of
some people
um but me i had high expectations based
on the trailers
i was talking about on this show from
when we started seeing commercials i was
like
i think i'm going to love this because i
think it's going to be [ __ ] sad like
i think there's a real
sadness at work here and it really it
was it was completely satisfying for me
i uh i did not i didn't feel like
oh if only they'd done this i do have a
question though about
um uh like it looked like a scheduling
thing
where you know darcy hits hayward's car
and then later on they're like darcy
didn't stick around like she didn't like
that kind of thing
really felt like darcy's on another
movie now we just gotta throw in a line
why she's not here i felt like
production
to me and stuff like that but it was
yeah i absolutely
[ __ ] loved it obviously i'll be
talking about forever man i'm so glad
uh they came on and talked about and got
to answer some questions i think we're
gonna get to one more question is that
correct jc let's do it
yeah we can do one more um this one
again
may stretch stretch our uh our luck here
but
um what is one fan theory
about your work that wasn't true but you
totally loved ooh that is actually a
good question
was there any fan theory that you were
like [ __ ] why didn't we do that
was there any that i wish we had done
not really i mean i loved the
i loved the you know everything down to
like the cicada on the
curtain that was mephisto everyone was
mephisto the mailman was with this dough
rabbit i was like the rabbit mr scratch
he's got let me just say something about
about senor scratchy we did we did have
something more
uh planned for senior scratchy which we
ultimately couldn't do just because the
finale we had so many different as i
said so many different chess pieces on
the
we did have a whole sequence where darcy
monica
ralph meet up with the kids and they're
in agatha's house and they
they think that maybe they should steal
the darkhold um from the basement
because the kids had seen it when they
were down there
being held hostage by agatha they go
down there to get the book
and they're reaching for the book and
the rabbit hops up in front of the book
and they're like i don't think you're
scratchy he's the best and then like
reach over to pet him and he like hisses
and then this whole american werewolf in
london transformation happens and
the rabbit turns into this big demon
right into her like familiar you know
and uh and then goonies set piece ensues
with all sorts of fun
as they try to escape from the rabbit
you know but we didn't we
we shot it but didn't finish all the vfx
and stuff for it um
and it was it was a great sequence it
was super fun everyone was great in it
um but we ended up you know moving it
aside because it was a huge sort of
detour
in the middle of everything else that we
had going so yeah so senor scratchy
did have a little bit more left on the
cutting room floor i look forward to the
12-hour
matt shackman cut yes
the matt shackman's wanda vision spared
no expense
right exactly yeah you know what it's
probably better that
the rabbit wasn't like didn't turn into
a monster because then you'd have
everybody going now that's mabisto for
you that's great exactly
or they'd be like come on it's gotta be
fing fang boom there's gotta be
something connected to the marvel
universe because nothing
can just nothing could just be a cicada
in the marvel universe
there's got to be another story uh let's
see what do we got
uh do we want to do one more this is
kind of a fun one well that was the one
i'm sorry
i just asked for another one go ahead um
if matt could play
one hero in the mcu who would you want
to play
that's not already in it excellent
question to end on matt
well that's another cam
i was a former actor maybe like uh simon
williams maybe wondering
wonder man yeah there were theories that
wonder man was the um
the remember jimmy wu was like i've got
somebody right
in protective custody or whatever uh and
it was and and somebody was like that's
simon williams the wonder man
i don't know where people get this man
just the idea
wish fulfillment but they're so
convincing and all you have to do is put
that into a website headline
and i'll totally buy that where i'm like
gotta be true they put it in print
totally um you did an amazing thing
sir i'm glad you did everything you did
in your life because it led you to
making this thing and this is one of my
favorite things i've ever [ __ ] seen
uh thank you for honoring these
characters and thank you for honoring
the work of uh of jack and who's the
other the producer lady
mary lovanos oh two uh you guys brain
trust to the storytelling
absolutely wonderful you got tremendous
performances
out of two actors who give wonderful
performances all the time but like
i bet you they respect the [ __ ] out of a
guy who's the theater guy as well they
probably like
showed up a bit more for work because
you got some credibility on your side
besides like your long body of work man
actors love that kind of live theater
[ __ ]
so congratulations sir uh more continued
success but even if you never do another
thing
this to me is your do the right thing
like when i saw do the right thing
people like well like well what's he
gonna do next i'm like he never has to
do [ __ ] anything next
spike lee just made do the right thing
you ain't gotta do nothing
for the rest of your life you made one a
vision but i'm sure you'll continue on
and make wonderful great things just
like spike lee went on after do the
right thing
thank you i appreciate that
congratulations you you made a show
that's about something
and you know now more than ever it is so
important that that
even that what feels like should be
ephemeral and what feels like should be
thrown away and could be and could get
away
with just being disposable cotton candy
bubble gum
you know piffle it isn't you know it's
about something
and i think that that that's incredibly
important and you should be very proud
of the work that you and your team did
because it it didn't have to be
and i'm so glad that it is wow thank you
i appreciate it thank you guys so much
for watching and enjoying it and thanks
for this time i appreciate it
oh my god thank you and thanks for
coming on talking to everybody thank you
to the audience for hanging out tonight
uh we're gonna skip the news because
what [ __ ] news is there beyond this
this was the news for heaven's sakes but
look we got to pick the brain
of the [ __ ] responsible you
know never mind we always sit around and
go like imagine therefore what were they
thinking
we literally got to find out what was
being thought man
uh thank you to matt for joining us
thank you to the audience for joining us
thanks jc for
making all this work and whatnot thank
you marvel for continuing to make [ __ ]
that i want to watch and whatnot
captured my heart and imagination and uh
we'll be back next week with more sadly
ain't no marijuana vision to talk about
but you know i can't i
will be referencing it for from now
until the end yeah
we'll find something maybe we'll play a
game of yahtzee
and we'll talk about that to fill the
void
there will be there will be something to
talk about uh ladies and gentlemen that
is uh fat man beyond for this week i'm
kevin smith
i'm mark bernardin and our guest has
been
matt jackman uh tune in next time same
fat time
same fat channel smodcast.com or
youtube.com kevin smith what is uh
la a death if not love persevering
ladies and gentlemen that's a terrible
line to go out on
jeff's kiss
you